programming throwdown episode 168 good oh take it away patrick welcome everyone uh starting with a bit of a uh a rant is that i don't know man it's so negative i have something to rant about we have a cup a pair of rants oh okay is there a word for that you know there's like a flock of geese is there a word for a gaggle of rants okay all right going to buy right so one of the things that has been like a recurring theme and it feels like it's getting worse now i guess like to set the context if this is your uh first first episode with us you maybe you don't know but i'm i don't know how you would call the like role of software i do so maybe it's particular to the kinds of software i do but it's it's been persistent so it's some combination of embedded application engineering maybe web is a bit better
Programming Throwdown 第 168 期，好的，Patrick，交给你了。大家好，呃，先从一点点抱怨开始吧，我知道这听起来很消极，但我确实有些抱怨。我们有一对抱怨，哦，好吧，你知道有没有专门的词来形容这个吗？就像一群鹅叫“gaggle of geese”，那抱怨的一群叫什么？“gaggle of rants”？好吧，行吧，开始吧。所以，其中一个反复出现的主题，而且感觉现在越来越严重了，我想先交代一下背景，如果这是你第一次听我们的节目，你可能不知道，我不知道该怎么称呼我所做的软件开发角色，可能这和我做的软件类型有关，但这种情况一直存在，它是嵌入式应用工程的某种组合，也许 Web 开发会好一点。
i don't know um but maybe back end is pretty similar and that is the number of things you're expected to know how to do on a computer that really don't have anything to do with programming but you're just like you're supposed to know how to take care of it like just random things not just the kind of slightly strange things like you need to know how to set up your computer like plug in the keyboard and mouse and you know monitor not admittedly these things aren't hard and most of us know how to do them but like this isn't really related to programming like you could not know how to swap hard drives on your computer install new ram but occasionally someone the other day had a hard drive you know crap out and and so the it person just like sent them a new hard drive in the
我不知道，嗯，也许后端也差不多，那就是你被期望在电脑上掌握的事情太多了，而这些事情实际上和编程毫无关系，但你就是被要求知道怎么处理它们。不仅仅是那些稍微有点奇怪的事情，比如你需要知道如何设置你的电脑，比如插上键盘、鼠标和显示器，诚然，这些事情并不难，我们大多数人都知道怎么做，但这真的和编程无关。你可能不知道怎么更换电脑硬盘或安装新内存，但偶尔，前几天有人硬盘坏了，IT 人员就通过内部邮件给他们寄了一个新硬盘，说“嘿，装个新硬盘”之类的。
internal mail and like here installed a new hard drive or whatever now people i mean that is not common okay i mean weird right but like you wouldn't be also surprised that a programmer was expected to know like how to install their own hard drive like because it's i guess it's part of my rant it's just par for the course weird for you know the company or whatever but just you know not that but like you know dealing with errors in your operating system um you know finagling issues about network connectivity uh even if you don't develop a software that has anything to do with you know sockets and you know ip connections and just any of that stuff, you're still expected to know how to debug that at some some level and kind of figure it out. And then also things about just like setting up your develop environment, right?
现在，我是说，这并不常见，好吧，我是说这很奇怪，对吧？但如果一个程序员被期望知道如何安装自己的硬盘，你也不会感到惊讶，因为我想这是我抱怨的一部分，这在公司里是司空见惯的，或者不管怎样，但这还不是全部，比如处理操作系统中的错误，处理网络连接问题，即使你开发的软件与套接字（sockets）和 IP 连接毫无关系，你仍然被期望在某种程度上知道如何调试这些问题并弄清楚它们。还有关于设置开发环境的事情，对吧？
Like having your ID ID set up properly and getting all of the compilers working and all of that. There's no just like, sit down and here's a text box. And your sort of expectation is to just, you know, type in the program and i guess that's true with a lot of jobs there's like lots of extra stuff you need to know um but but it gets really esoteric so i develop in c++ which is especially bad so just the amount of like how to get your systems libraries installed correctly so they can be accessed but the same is true python even when using pip or virtual environment or whatever like you still have issues with like conflicting packages and package managers
比如正确设置你的 IDE，让所有的编译器都能正常工作等等。没有那种“坐下来，这就是一个文本框”的情况。你的期望就是，你知道，输入程序，我想很多工作都是这样，有很多额外的东西你需要知道，但它变得非常深奥。我用 C++ 开发，这尤其糟糕，所以仅仅是关于如何正确安装系统库以便它们能被访问，这就很麻烦。Python 也是如此，即使在使用 pip 或虚拟环境时，你仍然会遇到包冲突和包管理器的问题。
and linux stuff so it's not sufficient to just you know most people would know windows or mac os but probably need to know linux you know and how to debug various issues when you mess something up in one of your paths and you know how to have your profile set up and so anyways my rant is just becoming like there's some stuff for like fixing this and virtual development environments but they're not here yet and i guess i would say they can't come soon enough yeah i mean a couple of things there one we have this wiki page for it's called landing your first pull request and it's a freaking enormous like there's just like an insane amount of things you have to do um we have a github bot that actually merges
还有 Linux 的东西，所以只知道 Windows 或 macOS 是不够的，可能还需要了解 Linux，以及当你弄乱路径时如何调试各种问题，以及如何设置你的配置文件。所以总之，我的抱怨就是，虽然有一些东西可以解决这个问题，比如虚拟开发环境，但它们还没普及，我想说它们来得越快越好。是的，这里有几件事，第一，我们有一个维基页面，叫“提交你的第一个 Pull Request”，它简直大得离谱，有太多你必须做的事情。我们有一个 GitHub 机器人，它实际上会合并所有的 Pull Request。
all the pull requests like you don't actually merge them yourself and so yeah you have to like you know run all the unit tests and then run lint, and there's a billion different kinds of Lint. There's MyPy, and then there's Flake, which both, I guess, check different things. They're not totally overlapping. And then there's all these other things. As you said, there's the pip dependencies, making sure that's all okay.
你不需要自己合并它们，所以是的，你必须运行所有的单元测试，然后运行 Lint，而且有十亿种不同的 Lint。有 MyPy，还有 Flake，我想它们检查的东西不同，它们并不完全重叠。然后还有所有这些其他的东西。正如你所说的，还有 pip 依赖项，确保这一切都没问题。
And then to your point, do this wacky thing where everything runs in a Docker container. Like you actually can't run anything on your own computer because as you said, you don't have any of the libraries or anything. So, so everything has to run inside this Docker container, which is kind of painful. If you need to use GDB, you know, or any type of debugger, you have to do this remote GDB or you TCP into your own computer. It's just weird.
然后回到你的观点，做这种古怪的事情，让一切都在 Docker 容器中运行。你实际上不能在自己的电脑上运行任何东西，因为正如你所说的，你没有任何库或任何东西。所以，一切都必须在 Docker 容器内运行，这有点痛苦。如果你需要使用 GDB，或者任何类型的调试器，你必须进行远程 GDB，或者通过 TCP 连接到你自己的电脑。这太奇怪了。
But yeah, I mean, it's like a huge laundry list of stuff. And none of it has anything to do with the code that you wrote. That entire document, you could just be adding a semicolon and you have to go through that whole thing. The other part of it is, I think in general, just stepping back a bit, there's just enormous cognitive overhead that there wasn't before. I was thinking about travel agents and how you'd have a travel agent kind of book everything for you and find the right flight and all of that um now travel agents are even before our time really i mean i actually never used one but um but now you know you have to do all that yourself and and you know the search and retrieval is really good so that you know normal normies normal people like us could do it at all but um but still it's like
但确实，这就像一个巨大的待办事项清单。而且这些都与你编写的代码无关。整个文档，你可能只是想加一个分号，却必须经历整个过程。另一部分是，我认为总的来说，退一步看，现在有巨大的认知负担，以前是没有的。我当时在想旅行社，以前旅行社帮你预订一切，找到合适的航班等等。现在旅行社甚至在我们那个时代之前就真的没落了，我是说我从来没用过，但现在你必须自己做所有这些，而且搜索和检索功能真的很好，所以像我们这样的普通人也能做到，但仍然，这就像是
cognitive overhead that you didn't have before and uh you know i think the same thing with the bank and you have an issue with your amazon package or something it's just there's an extraordinary amount of cognitive overhead and i think as a programmer it also just seems to keep increasing the amount of things that you have to do i was watching some movie the other day i don't even remember what movie it was and it was just one of the funny standout things was the person wanted to fly somewhere so they drove to the airport to go inside the airport to book a ticket they weren't flying they just like went to the airport for the purpose of like talking to a booking agent and booking a ticket and it was like oh i yeah i guess that makes sense
以前没有的认知负担。你知道，我认为银行也是一样，如果你在亚马逊包裹上遇到问题，或者其他什么，都有巨大的认知负担。我认为作为一名程序员，你必须做的事情似乎也在不断增加。前几天我在看一部电影，我不记得是什么电影了，其中一个有趣的突出点是，那个人想飞往某地，于是他开车去机场，走进机场去预订机票。他们不是在飞行，他们只是为了和预订代理交谈并预订机票而去机场，当时我就想，哦，是的，我想这说得通。
like people did that like that you know or like you said you phoned up someone or phoned up uh yeah you know and i think that happened to me the other day we were trying to book something online it was having a glitch and we had to like talk to a person and like do it verbally and they were reciting back to us like the various times and it was just like oh man this is yeah in some ways it's lots better but as you pointed out like the number of tyranny of choice i guess like the number of things right from and the number and it just like everything becomes an analytical decision and yeah it's yeah i mean to riffing off your point you know i i i've never had a company send me a hard drive or anything like that but i did
就像人们过去那样，或者像你说的，你打电话给某人，是的，我想前几天我也遇到了这种情况，我们试图在线预订某样东西，它出了故障，我们不得不和一个人交谈，口头完成它，他们向我们复述各种时间，当时我就想，天哪，这在某些方面确实好多了，但正如你指出的，选择的暴政，我想，事情的数量，一切都变成了分析性的决定。是的，顺着你的观点，我从来没有遇到过公司给我寄硬盘之类的事情，但我确实
have a hardware failure um uh yesterday it was really weird i was on my computer and this is my personal computer um and then all of a sudden like steam was updating some game in the background and i was i was coding something up um i was actually working on which we should talk about at some point. But I was bringing that back. And all of a sudden, like, I look and I see, oh, Steam is updating some game. And it's been updating for almost the entire day. Uh-oh. And basically, you know, it's like a ton of triage.
昨天遇到了硬件故障，这真的很奇怪。我当时正在用电脑，这是我的个人电脑，突然间，Steam 在后台更新某个游戏，我当时正在编写一些东西，我实际上正在做那个，我们应该在某个时候谈谈。但我正在恢复它。突然间，我看到，哦，Steam 正在更新某个游戏。而且它已经更新了几乎一整天。糟糕。基本上，你知道，这就像大量的分类工作。
What I found out was my hard drive was only reading and writing at 800 kilobytes a second. And I was immediately yeah i was thinking oh man i'm gonna lose this hard drive you know and i just bought it and it has all my stuff on it and you know i started getting kind of nervous um but then i was like you know the i ran all the smart tests and diagnostics everything everything came back fine it's just nothing would actually finish like scanning the drive i thought maybe i needed to free up space but i didn't um and it turns out the sata cable was bad it went bad oh and i've basically been using the same sata cables for probably 15 years or something just because i keep you know when i get new ones they just go in a box and i just already have the other one plugged in a drive and i change it i'm not changing the drive and the seda cable at the same time really ever um so yeah i just swapped out the seda cable but it was
我发现我的硬盘读取和写入速度只有每秒 800 KB。我立刻就想，天哪，我要失去这个硬盘了，我刚买的，里面有我所有的东西，我开始感到有点紧张。但后来我运行了所有的 SMART 测试和诊断，一切都显示正常，只是没有任何东西能真正完成扫描驱动器。我以为我需要释放空间，但我没有。结果发现是 SATA 线坏了。我基本上 15 年来一直用同样的 SATA 线，因为我一直保留着它们，当我得到新的时，它们就放进盒子里，而我已经把旧的插在驱动器上了，我从来没有同时更换驱动器和 SATA 线。所以是的，我只是换了 SATA 线，但它
definitely it kind of scared me and to your point like like you know i don't know like we have to fix these things ourselves i don't really know like who i would even i don't know like we have to fix these things ourselves i don't really know like who i would even i don't think geek squad will come and go look at this homebrew machine that's i mean they will but they'll also do 100 other things you didn't want yeah that's right i'll never like five copies of norton antivirus or something uh yeah the other one i'll drop just here for anyone who runs into it hdmi cables are not all the same so over the years if you're still using a really old hdmi cable it may not be able to like support the proper bandwidth if you're trying to like you know do 4k blu-rays or something it's just something i was unaware of but really i didn't know that yeah wow how do you know is it is it printed on the cable or anything
确实吓到我了。回到你的观点，我们必须自己修理这些东西，我真的不知道，我想 Geek Squad 不会来修理这台自制机器，我是说他们会来，但他们也会做 100 件你不想让他们做的事。是的，没错，我可不想安装五份诺顿杀毒软件之类的。是的，另一个我要提的是，HDMI 线并不都是一样的。所以多年来，如果你还在使用非常旧的 HDMI 线，它可能无法支持适当的带宽，如果你试图做 4K 蓝光之类的，这是我以前不知道的，但真的，我不知道。是的，哇，你怎么知道的？线缆上有印字吗？
that's a great question to try it you just buy the one that has the bandwidth you want and use it. Well, you know, that's the advantage of us being our own geek squad is like, you know, if something doesn't work, you know, we can order a cable and it's only eight bucks. And it's like still a tiny fraction of the cost of getting someone to come to your house. So like if you order the cable cable it's wrong it's like well i have an upgraded cable now and i can keep debugging and then you end up with the uh the box of cables that every geek has in the closet which is just i have it and actually folks at home you know we stopped doing video because uh we felt like we had to you know get all prettied up and
这是个好问题，要尝试它，你只需购买你想要的带宽的线缆并使用它。嗯，你知道，这就是我们成为自己的 Geek Squad 的优势，如果有什么东西坏了，我们可以订购一根线，只要 8 块钱。这仍然只是请人到你家修理费用的极小一部分。所以如果你订错了线，那也没关系，我只是多了一根升级后的线，我可以继续调试，最后你会在壁橱里得到一个每个极客都有的线缆盒。实际上，家里的朋友们，我们停止制作视频了，因为我们觉得我们必须打扮得漂漂亮亮的，
everything so we stopped doing that but but folks at home can't see the giant box of cables that patrick can see in the background um oh another thing that happened to me last week so i went through a period where i was ordering a ton of stuff from aliexpress and these these like straight from china things and uh slowly slowly it's like come to be just a terrible investment. And this is really the capstone on it. I have a Raspberry Pi 4. And I bought this thing that could control multiple servos because every year my Halloween scare bot just gets more and more extreme. And so it's at the point now where I needed something to control a bunch of servos. So there's this little I2C module communicates over I2C controls a bunch of servos. And the way it works is you connect the I2C pins to the Raspberry Pi, you connect
所以我们停止了那样做，但家里的朋友们看不到 Patrick 背景中那个巨大的线缆盒。哦，上周发生在我身上的另一件事，我经历了一段从 AliExpress 订购大量东西的时期，这些直接来自中国的东西，慢慢地，它变成了一个糟糕的投资。这是最糟糕的。我有一个 Raspberry Pi 4。我买了那个可以控制多个舵机的东西，因为每年我的万圣节惊吓机器人都会变得越来越极端。所以现在我需要一些东西来控制一堆舵机。有一个小的 I2C 模块，通过 I2C 通信控制一堆舵机。它的工作方式是你将 I2C 引脚连接到 Raspberry Pi，你连接
the 3.3 volts to the Raspberry Pi, and that powers the board and sends all the signals. And then separately in the servo controller, you connect like a power supply, right? To power these servos. Because servos use way more electricity than the whole Raspberry Pi, right? So even one of them probably does. So I set it all up. It looks all correct.
3.3 伏电源到 Raspberry Pi，这为板子供电并发送所有信号。然后单独在舵机控制器中，你连接一个电源，对吧？为这些舵机供电。因为舵机使用的电量比整个 Raspberry Pi 多得多，对吧？所以即使其中一个可能也是如此。所以我设置好了一切。看起来完全正确。
One thing that was kind of a tip-off was my power supply was saying it was plugged in when it wasn't that should have been a tip-off that something bad was going to happen so but but being an idiot i i plugged it in anyways and smoke started coming out of the raspberry pi and the raspberry pi got completely nuked um the the the sd card burnt my finger when i popped it out and uh i was so so mad you know first i was thought what did i do and i'm looking at everything and it looks fine and then you know i get the multimeter and it turns out this is shorted and it's just a bad component that i that i got you know as cheap as possible trying to save i i saved two dollars off what it would cost on amazon and i fried like 120 bucks worth of equipment
有一件事有点预兆，就是我的电源显示它已插入，但实际上并没有，那应该是一个预兆，说明会有坏事发生。但作为一个白痴，我还是把它插上了，烟雾开始从 Raspberry Pi 中冒出来，Raspberry Pi 被彻底烧毁了。SD 卡在我拔出来时烫伤了我的手指，我当时太生气了，首先我以为我做了什么，我检查了一切，看起来没问题，然后我拿了万用表，结果发现这个东西短路了，这只是一个坏组件，我为了省钱，试图尽可能便宜地买，我比在亚马逊上买省了两美元，结果烧毁了价值 120 美元的设备。
um and i was so freaking mad unbelievably mad. But what can you do, man? I just had to throw the raspberry pie in the garbage and get another one and move on. Yeah, I guess there's a tip there too, just for people who want to play with that kind of stuff. Well, first of all, there's a high potential the stuff you would have bought at Amazon would have been exactly the same,
我当时太生气了，难以置信地生气。但你能做什么呢，伙计？我只能把 Raspberry Pi 扔进垃圾桶，再买一个，然后继续前进。是的，我想这里也有一个建议，给那些想玩这种东西的人。嗯，首先，你从亚马逊买的东西很有可能完全一样，
just like pre-labeled. But the second thing is do not plug things you get like that for the first time into your computer usb port for for basically the same reason so if you have some usb powered device or whatever you get off like get uh what do you i don't know what you call that like the one that like a wall wart or something else like a splitter uh no like uh don't like even if it needs data right like you need to like like a thumb drive or whatever right so a thumb drive could have a short the same way but if you at least plug it into something that
只是预先贴了标签而已。但第二件事是，不要把你第一次得到的这种东西插进你的电脑 USB 端口，原因基本相同。所以如果你有某种 USB 供电的设备，或者其他你从哪里得到的，我不知道你怎么称呼它，就像那种墙上插头或者其他什么，比如分线器，不，就像，即使它需要数据，对吧？你需要像 U 盘之类的，对吧？所以 U 盘也可能以同样的方式短路，但如果你至少把它插在
isn't going to like an old computer or something that isn't like your nice computer because if you have a short in it but you know like usb drives are just a little different but i'm thinking like one of these dev boards or something you soldered up and you accidentally you know solder across it plug it into something that will basically like you're okay losing rather than your computer computer one because yeah the same thing can happen and then you'll fry your usb port or even your motherboard it's bad days yep yep and this is the this is the second time something like this has happened to me and and uh the first time was my fault first First time was totally my fault. This time is not my fault, but, but the one telltale sign is if things have power that shouldn't, that was sort of the common denominator. It's like this, this thing is not yet plugged in
不是你的好电脑上，或者不是旧电脑上，因为如果它短路了，你知道，USB 驱动器有点不同，但我想到的是这些开发板，或者你焊接的东西，你不小心短路了，把它插在一些你基本上不介意失去的东西上，而不是你的主电脑，因为是的，同样的事情可能会发生，然后你会烧毁你的 USB 端口甚至主板，那会很糟糕。是的，是的，这是第二次发生这种事了，第一次是我的错，第一次完全是我的错。这次不是我的错，但一个明显的迹象是，如果东西在不该有电的时候有电，那通常是共同点。就像这个东西还没有插上
the wall and the light is on and I'm getting a voltage reading on it. That's all you're only supposed to get when it's plugged into the wall like that right there if you ever see something on that shouldn't be on um yeah i told the story years ago but in my first project i did it on a metal bench and uh shorted everything i mean that was incredibly dumb but but you know the sign there was you know that the lights were still on and i hadn't plugged it in yet so that's the thing to look for free power yeah i mean i thought that i had a scarabot and a perpetual energy machine what i actually had was just accurate smoke yeah all right is it time for our news of the show let's do it what's your news all right so my first one well i guess these are mostly links
墙上的插座，灯却亮着，我得到了电压读数。那只有在插上墙上插座时才应该有的，如果你看到不该亮的东西亮了，是的，我几年前讲过这个故事，但在我的第一个项目中，我把它放在金属工作台上，结果把一切都短路了，那真是太蠢了，但你知道，那里的迹象是灯还亮着，而我还没插上电源，所以这就是要注意的事情，免费的电。是的，我以为我有一个惊吓机器人和一个永动机，但我实际上只有准确的烟雾。是的，好了，是时候进行节目新闻了吗？我们开始吧，你的新闻是什么？好的，所以我的第一个，嗯，我想这些大多是链接。
i don't think we have any news i guess i have a little bit of news so my first one is a blog uh this is smartguess.is um anyways and it's talking about software estimates which are notoriously very difficult i i don't even think it's a junior senior thing i think it's just very difficult i'm thankful that i'm not in a high stakes software negotiating like dev estimate thing because i just i can't imagine but they were kind of making analogy that it's like negotiating with a meteorologist um there's some caveats i immediately sort of got the content i like read it to make sure you know like but just reading that it was one of those ones like just reading
我不认为我们有什么新闻，我想我有一点新闻。所以我的第一个是一个博客，这是 smartguess.is，总之，它在谈论软件估算，众所周知，这非常困难。我甚至不认为这是初级或高级的问题，我认为这只是非常困难。我很庆幸我没有参与高风险的软件谈判或开发估算，因为我无法想象，但他们做了一个类比，就像和气象学家谈判一样。有一些警告，我立刻理解了内容，我读了它以确保你知道，但仅仅阅读它，它就是那种仅仅阅读
the headline was enough for me to derive like lots of value and smile from it then the person is talking about accurately so like if you you're keeping all the bounds the same like keeping the requirements the same and all of this like the estimate is the estimate to ask the estimate to be lower is is is just like making the you know just making your stuff come late or you know becoming a problem and no one fusses when you come in too low they only fuss if you come in too high so there's always this pressure to come in faster and shorter um and you know that's that's just kind of, it's kind of silly. I know you could change the requirements, you can split things up, you could reassign new people or
标题就足以让我获得很多价值并从中微笑的文章。然后那个人在谈论准确性，所以如果你保持所有界限不变，保持需求不变，所有这些，估算就是估算。要求估算更低，只会让你的东西迟到，或者成为一个问题。当你估算太低时，没有人会大惊小怪，只有当你估算太高时，他们才会大惊小怪。所以总是有一种压力要求更快、更短，你知道，这有点愚蠢。我知道你可以改变需求，你可以拆分事情，你可以重新分配新的人员或
more people. I mean, those things are, they're all possible. But in general, yeah, like the estimate is the estimate for the, you know, kind of statement of work. And so trying to negotiate with it just doesn't work. But you know as i've as i've become more and more of a person you know trying to work with others i i will say i do find that sometimes people give me very very low estimates and i tried to tell them in general don't don't and someone in someone was reading some commentary about about this this post as well this one was pointing out correctly that uh programmers naively think they're going to have like their high output like peak output for how long would it take to
更多的人。我是说，这些事情，它们都是可能的。但总的来说，是的，估算就是工作说明书的估算。所以试图协商它根本行不通。但你知道，随着我越来越成为一个试图与他人合作的人，我会说我确实发现有时人们给我的估算非常非常低，我试图告诉他们总的来说不要这样做。有人在阅读关于这篇文章的评论时也指出，程序员天真地认为他们会有像他们的高产出，即峰值产出，来解决这个问题，但我们忘记的是，你一天中实际上有多少时间处于峰值产出？你知道，你必须去开会，你会被打断，你在帮助代码审查别人的东西，所以这里有一个平衡，即专注时间是这么多小时，但你不会有所有的专注时间。此外，你通常需要估算日历时间，而你的日历时间，你知道，比你想象的要少得多。是的，我是说我在这里真正挣扎的是，人们非常高估了可替代性，我不知道这是否是正确的词，
solve this problem at peak output but then we forget is how much of the day are you actually at peak output you know are you have to go to meetings you're getting interrupted you're helping code review other people's stuff so there's this balance between like yeah focused time it's this amount of hours but you're not going to have all focused time and additionally you kind of often need to estimate calendar time and your calendar time you know you have a lot less than you think yeah i mean the thing where i'm really struggling here right now is is is this idea that that folks are much more like people really overestimate how fungible, I don't know if that's the right word,
但例如，你谈到了做嵌入式和 Web 等等。很少有人拥有那种技能组合。所以如果有人真的懂嵌入式 DSP，而你的网站进度落后了，你会听到人们说，哦，只要把这个人加到网站项目中就能更快完成。然后它从来没有好结果，因为原因太多了。
but like, so for example, you talked about doing embedding and web and all of that. Very few people have that union of skills. And so if there's somebody who really knows embedded DSP and you're behind schedule on the website, you'll hear folks say, oh, just add this person to the website to get it done faster. And then it just never works out well because it's just for so many reasons.
我是说，第一，那个人不想建立网站。他们想继续做他们的 DSP 工作。第二，那个人现在必须接受其他技能的培训，这需要时间。这可能是一件好事，但绝对不会加快进度。所以我认为这是一个问题，我们处于这种中间阶段，在许多公司，每个人仍然被称为软件工程师。但我感觉如果还没改变的话，那可能会改变。但是的，这是另一个问题。就像，我们有八个人。只要把所有八个人都放在这个东西上，它就会完成。
I mean, one, the person doesn't want to build a website. They want to keep doing their DSP work. Two, it's like that person has to now get trained in that other skill, which takes time. And it might be a good thing to do, but it's definitely not going to accelerate the schedule. And so I think this is like a problem of we're in this sort of in-between phase where everyone's still called a software engineer at a lot of companies. But I feel like that will probably change if it hasn't already. But yeah, that's another problem. It's like, we have eight people. Just put all eight people on this thing and it'll get done.
就像，嗯，它并不是那样工作的。我的新闻故事是宣布 Python 进入 Excel，所以你知道我们是未来的预测者，Patrick，我们基本上是令人惊叹的。所以我们几个月前谈论过 Excel，谈论过如果能在 Excel 中使用 Python 或其他东西会很棒。果然，微软，他们一定是在听 Programming Throwdown。他们宣布了 Python in Excel。实际上，Guido 是我听到这个消息的第一个地方。他在 Twitter 上发布了它，但它也出现在新闻和所有地方。
It's like, well, it doesn't really work that way. My news story is announcing python in excel so you know we are predictors of the future patrick we're basically we're basically amazing so we talked about excel months ago two or three months ago and talked about how it would uh be awesome if you could do python or these other things in excel sure enough microsoft they must have been listening to Programming Throwdown. They announced Python in Excel. And actually, Guido is the first place I heard it from. He posted about it on Twitter, but it had also been on the news and everything.
这真的很棒。我认为它的工作方式是它启动了一个临时的虚拟环境来执行，这是让数百万从未听说过 Python 的人接触到它的好方法，我想对于知道如何使用 Python 的人来说，不再对“我不明白如何让这个 Excel 函数做我想做的事”感到沮丧，这也是反过来的。是的，这是真的，这是真的。如果你需要做一些真正高级的统计工作，你需要 SciPy，但你知道，你在 Excel 中没有简单的方法可以得到它。我想知道，那些做 Excel Python 的公司，比如有一个我想叫 xbb，但有这些 Excel Python 绑定，
And it's pretty awesome. I think the way it works is it spins up and sort of like a ephemeral virtual environment to execute this is a great way to get um you know python in the hands of millions and millions of people who up until now probably never even heard about it and i guess the reverse for people who know how to do python to not be frustrated with i don't understand how to get this excel function to do what i want yeah that's true it's true if you need to you know do like some real advanced stat stuff you need sci-pi but you know you don't have any easy way to get an excel i wonder you know all those companies that do kind of excel python like there's one i think it's called xbb but there's these uh excel you know python bindings
他们商业化销售这些东西，那些人可能对这个消息不高兴，但我的意思是，我认为对于整个社区来说，这是一个巨大的胜利。如果你还没看过它，我只是前几天在看它，因为我正在尝试用数据透视表做一些事情，别问。总之，有一个，我不知道该怎么说，著名的，有一个经典，所以 Joel Spolsky，我想他以前在微软，最初创立了 Fog Creek Software，我觉得几年前我没怎么听说过他了，但我感觉他是那种，他有一个大博客，是 Joel on Software，我想是的，没错，Joel，是的，他就像一个推动开发者生产力的人，
that they sell commercially those people are probably not happy with this news but i mean i think for the overall uh community it's a huge win if you've not watched it i just i was watching it the other day because i was trying to do something with pivot tables don't ask anyways uh there's a there's a i i don't know what to say famous there's a classic so joel spolsky i think he used to be at microsoft originally founded fog creek software like i feel like a few years ago i don't hear that much about him anymore but i feel like he was one of the sort of uh he had a big blog it was at joel joel on software i think yeah that's right joel yeah and he would he was like one like pushing for like developer productivity
比如买好的椅子和更多的显示器，基本上就是善待你的工程师，在那个时候，这可能并不常见，或者我不是说不是，现在比以前更常见了，我感觉他是推动这一点的那些人之一。总之，他有一个 YouTube 视频，你可以搜索一下，“You Suck at Excel”，他展示了实际上你可以用 Excel 做很多事情，比如数据透视表，或者几乎，有一些 VC 说这是，每隔一段时间，我不记得节奏是什么，基本上，有人带着一个初创公司出现，而这基本上可以用 Excel 中的数据透视表解决。
and like you know getting nice chairs and more monitors and like you he was like one like pushing for like developer productivity and like you know getting nice chairs and more monitors and like you know basically like treat your engineers you know kind of nice at a time when uh maybe that wasn't as common or i don't say wasn't uh it happens more now than it used to uh and i feel like he was one of the the people that pushed for that anyways he has a youtube video you can kind of search it you suck at excel and uh he sort of shows that actually like you can do a lot with Excel, like pivot tables, or almost, there's some VC people who say this is like, every so often, you know, I forget what the cadence is, that basically, someone shows up with a startup that is basically could be solved with just a pivot table in Excel.
所以，你知道，大多数人低估了你仅仅通过粘贴所有数据并运行函数能做多少事情。是的，完全正确。所以，是的，大家一定要去看看，如果你们在使用它，请告诉我们你们是如何使用它的。是的，我想看看，我猜我看到它需要在我想要解决问题时非常容易被 Google 搜索到，有人会放上“这是 Python 代码”。是的，这是 80% 的解决方案。是的，
And so, you know, most people underestimate just how much you can do uh with just pasting all your data and and you know running the functions on it yeah totally totally um so yeah folks definitely check that out and uh report back if you're using it let us know how you're using it yeah i want to see i guess i saw i need it needs to be eminently googleable when i want to solve something someone to put like here here's the Python here. Yeah. Here's the like 80% solution. Yeah,
没错。我们的 Discord 里有很多不和谐的声音。所以，大家在 Discord 上非常活跃，这真的很酷。所以，你知道，
that's right. There's been a lot of discord in our discord. So, uh, folks have been very active in discord, which is really cool. So, you know,
通常我们总是说给我们发邮件，邮件，邮件，但你也可以去 Discord，那里有一个完整的社区，这很不错。
generally we always say email us, emails, emails, but, but, uh, you can also go on the discord and there's a whole community of people there, which is pretty neat.
我们不是 Discourse，Discord 上有 Discourse。哦，你是对的。Discord 听起来像是不和，对吧？哦，不。Discord 里有和谐。我的下一篇文章是《高效软件工程师的七个习惯》。这是在博客 makings.com 上，这是，哦，我不知道，这是那种
We're not discourse, there's discourse on Discord. Oh, you're right. Discord would be like disagreement, right? Oh no. There's harmony in Discord. My next article is Seven Habits of Highly Effective Software Engineers. This is at the blog, makings dot com uh and this is oh i don't i don't know it's one of those kind
经典的职场东西，如果你在一家大公司，他们提供自我提升培训，你会得到《高效能人士的七个习惯》，这些事情你知道，我不知道，每当我看到这些，我觉得这些事情你都知道，他们只是给它起了一个吸引人的名字。所以，你知道，高效能人士总是寻找双赢的解决方案。所以不要妥协，你寻找双赢的方法，让你试图达成协议的人变得更好，也让你自己变得更好。所以这只是我觉得，我不知道，有点显而易见，但你知道它们有一个框架很有帮助，也许它们是好的。总之，这个人有《高效软件工程师的七个习惯》，大概是模仿那个
of like classic corporate things if you ever like if you're if you had a big company and they offer like sort of self-betterment training you'll get the seven habits of highly effective people and it's things you know i don't know whenever take these, I feel like it's things you kind of know, they're just like putting a catchy name on it. So like, you know, highly effective people always look for win-win solutions. So don't compromise, you know, you look for win-win ways for, you know, what the person you're trying to reach agreement with makes them better and it makes you better. So it's just kind of like things that I feel are, I don't know, a little a little obvious but you know they're helpful to have a framework and and maybe maybe they're you know good anyways so this person has seven habits of highly effective software engineers presumably riffing on that
同样的东西。我不知道我读没读过它们，但去读读看。第一个是“积极原型化新想法”，那个真的引起了我的共鸣。我觉得总的来说这很难，但人们不愿意仅仅致力于尝试困难的部分。首先，识别困难的部分并不容易，但试图找到一些核心的困难部分，写一点代码，说服自己你的方法有效，或者也许你把它扔掉，也许你不扔掉，但告诉自己你会把它扔掉，你不是想把它做对，然后你再做一次。但也尝试限制它，尝试把它做小。所以我感觉这是人们可能会错过的事情之一。他
same same thing um i i don't know that i read them or not but but go read them you know the first one is like actively prototype new ideas and that one really you know sort of resonates with me is uh i feel in general it is difficult but people sort of are unwilling to just commit to trying kind of like the hard bit well first identifying the hard bit is not easy but trying to like find some like core hard bit and like just write a little bit of code and convince yourself that your approach works or that and like maybe you throw it away maybe you don't but like tell yourself you you know kind of will throw it away you're not trying to get it right and then you're going to do it again but also you know try to bound it try to make it small and so i feel like this is one of those uh you know things that that people can miss out so he
有关于代码审查的文档，只是把事情做完。所以，我觉得去读读看，我不会读完所有七个，我想那是个剧透，然后我会窃取流量，所以我不会，所以去读读那篇文章。是的，我是说那个立刻引起我共鸣的是“快速及时的代码审查”。我记得当我还是工程师时，当人们把代码审查搁置数周时，我会感到难以置信的沮丧，那比任何事情都更让我抓狂。而且我认为发生这种情况的原因是，至少，我不知道，我不知道你是否像这样，Patrick，你可能更
has sort of you know documentation about code reviews just getting stuff done so um i feel like go read that i won't i won't read you all seven i guess that's a spoiler then then i'll steal traffic so i won't uh so go so go read that that post yeah i mean the one that really resonates to me right off the bat is a quick and timely code reviews i remember when i um was engineer i would get so unbelievably frustrated when you know people would sit on a code review for weeks um that would just grind my gears more than anything else and you know i i think the reason why it happens is at least i don't know i don't know if you're like this patrick you might be more
有条理，但我会经历爆发期，会有两三周的时间，我会把难以置信的精力投入到我正在做的任何工作上，然后我会有一两周的时间，老实说，我不会真的那么努力工作，它会平均下来，所以效果很好。但我是一个爆发型的工作者，所以当我在那个爆发期，而有人就是不审查代码，那基本上切断了所有的能量，就像它被浪费了。然后，当他们审查它时，我已经没那么感兴趣了。所以你最终得到的结果就是因为这个而没有任何进展，对吧？所以，要认识到的一点是，当你在审查时，
methodical but i go through bursts where there will be like two three weeks where i will just put an unbelievable amount of energy into whatever work thing i'm doing and then i'll have a couple of weeks where you know i honestly like won't work really that hard and it averages out you know so it works out well but i'm very bursty worker and so when i'm in that you know burst and someone just doesn't review a code well that basically cuts all that energy short like it's kind of wasted and then you know by the time they review it now i'm like not that interested in it anymore and so it's just you what you end up with is not making any progress because of that right um so so that's one thing to recognize is like when you're reviewing that
那个人刚刚写完，他们可能真的很投入，所以你可能不投入，但你至少得假装你很投入，为了代码审查。是的，我认为爆发型工作是其中的一部分，我认为这对代码审查者也适用。我想我尝试与人们沟通，安排时间，在一天结束时，或者在你开始工作之前，或者当你不在专注状态时去进行代码审查，这样，正如你所说的，其他人就不会被阻塞。然后我们也尝试建立文化，比如多长时间，如果两天内没有人审查你的代码，你可以开始 ping 人，说“嘿，有人审查我的代码吗”，但不要在发送后 30 分钟就开始 ping
person just wrote that they're probably like really into it and so you might not be into it but you have to at least pretend like you're into it for the code review yeah i think the the bursty thing is part of it i think it works for the code reviewers too like i think i you know try to communicate to people like schedule time you know at the end of the day or you know before you start your work or just like something when you're out of focus to go do the code review so that you know like you said other people aren't kind of blocked and then we also try to establish cultural things like how long is it like you can start requiring if no one reviews your code within you know two days you know you can start pinging people and be like hey someone review my code um but don't start pinging
他们，说“嘿”，因为人们在专注，他们在做事情，或者他们在吃午饭等等。所以，你必须在双方都有合理的期望。但是的，尝试去处理它们。然后也要确保团队文化朝着能够进行代码审查的方向发展。所以不要有巨大的、未经沟通的 10,000 行变更，而且对基础设施有深远影响，这些讨论应该事先解决。人们试图在代码审查中解决团队战略决策是我的一个心病，这不好，那不是做这件事的正确地方。
them you know like 30 minutes after you send it in and be like, Hey, because, you know, people are focused, they're doing stuff or they're at lunch or whatever. Like, you know, that, you know, you gotta have reasonable, I guess on both sides. Um, but yeah, try to sort of get to them. And then also, you know, make sure that the team's culture like moves towards the ability to do code reviews. So not giant, not giant you know 10 000 line changes that weren't communicated and are like deeply impactful to infrastructure those discussions should be settled beforehand it is a pet peeve of mine that people try to sort of settle team strategy decisions in code review it's just it's not good that's not the right place to do it
是的，我是说有一件事我花了很多年才学会，我想我在节目中说过，但值得重复，那就是精通交互式 rebase 和 reset 等等。因为我知道，这是爆发型工作的一部分，我会最终得到一个 10,000 行的代码审查。而且我不知道有什么方法可以把它拆开。除了那种非常痛苦的事情，我只是，我不知道，从 github.com 复制粘贴之类的。我只是没有技术毅力去理解，好吧，这里有一种交互式的方法，我可以把这个变更拆分成 20 个不同的变更，并分别测试每一个。所以是的，如果你发现自己在提交巨大的同行评审，不要那样做，但不仅仅是不要那样做，学习那些你可以拆分它的技术和技术。好了，我的下一个是 Raspberry Pi 5 开始发货了。
yeah i mean one thing that took me many years to learn i think i've said on the show before but it's worth repeating is get get really good at interactive get rebasing and resetting and all of that because you know i would you know and this is part of the bursty thing you know i would end up with like a 10,000 line code review. And, you know, I didn't know that there was a way that I could break that apart. You know, a simple way other than like a really painful thing where I was just, I don't know, copying and pasting from github.com or something. Like I just didn't have the technical fortitude to understand like, okay, here's some interactive way where i can break this change into like 20 different changes and test each one in isolation so yeah if you find yourself submitting huge peer reviews don't do that but like but but not just don't do that like learn the techniques and the technology where you could break that down um all right my next one is raspberry pi 5 begin shipping
所以我，是的，我有一个 Raspberry Pi 5 在预购中。我一直这样做，自从我可能从你那里了解到 Raspberry Pi，Patrick，我觉得你是唯一一个我会和你有 Raspberry Pi 联系的人，但自从我接触到 Raspberry Pi，我就在它们发布时订购它们。而且，你知道，它需要很长时间才能送到你手中，但这是 Raspberry Pi 提供的基础价格，你不会被任何人加价。所以我的会在十二月某个时候到，他们是这么说的。但我订购了它，显然它在计算方面比 4 比 5 强得多，所以那会很有趣。我不知道我还要用它做什么，但那是待定的，我们得弄清楚。我感觉它有点，我当时在向 Jason 提到。
um so i uh yeah i have a raspberry pi 5 on back order i have always done this uh ever since actually i probably learned about raspberry pi from you patrick i feel like you're the only person who would uh who i'd have the raspberry pie connection with but um but ever since i got onto raspberry pie i've been ordering them when they came out um and you know it takes forever to get to you but it's the base price you know that raspberry pie offers you're not getting upcharged by anybody um so mine's coming sometime in december um that's what they say but uh yeah i ordered it apparently it's way stronger than the four uh in terms of compute um so that'll be kind of interesting i don't know what i'm going to do with it yet but uh yeah that's tbd we'll have to figure it out i feel like it's been a little i was mentioning to to the jason
嗯，我预订了一台树莓派5。我一直都是这样做的，其实自从我从帕特里克你那里了解到树莓派之后，我就一直这样。我觉得你是我唯一会谈论树莓派的人。自从我开始接触树莓派，只要有新款发布我就会订购。虽然到货时间很长，但那是树莓派提供的基础价格，不会被任何人加价。我的大概会在十二月左右到货，他们是这么说的。我订购了，据说它在计算能力方面比4代强得多，这会很有趣。我还不知道要用它做什么，这还有待决定，我们到时候再看。我觉得这有点……我刚才正跟杰森提到。
earlier when before when i saw that he you know had this up i feel like it's been so sad to me that the raspberry pies went from like a really low barrier entry into you know some embedded stuff to scares and hard to find and it used to be like that when they would first come out but then they would just be you know pretty ubiquitous but the supply chain thing they just never really sort of hit there there's like this combination i haven't looked at i think it's a combination of things but um you know it it's it's sort of unfortunate that it's a little less accessible you can't just go on amazon and get a reasonably priced one these days um this is you know become very difficult there's lots of cool things people have been doing and like you mentioned jason like hooking up to the i squared c ports is something
之前我看到他把这个弄出来的时候，我就觉得树莓派从一种门槛很低的嵌入式设备，变得稀缺且难以买到，这让我感到非常难过。以前它们刚出来的时候也是这样，但后来它们变得非常普及。然而供应链的问题导致它们一直没能恢复过来。我还没深入研究，但我认为这是多种因素共同作用的结果。嗯，你知道，它变得没那么容易获取，这确实有点遗憾。如今你没法直接在亚马逊上买到价格合理的树莓派了，这变得非常困难。人们一直在做很多很酷的事情，就像你提到的，杰森，连接到 I2C 端口就是其中之一。
a lot of people if you you know go on news articles or even myself replace them with just getting older like used enterprise mini pcs which are probably more powerful and they can run windows and stuff but they don't have all that library for hardware interactivity. So the embedded stuff is is not really workable there. If you just need something to be a NAS. Well, you can probably do pretty, pretty good for yourself not using a Raspberry Pi. But for all those hardware embedded projects, like it's really it's really the best sort of easy introduction to that. And it's just, yeah, I'm excited.
很多人，如果你去看看新闻文章，甚至我自己，都会用旧的企业级迷你电脑来代替它们。这些电脑可能性能更强，能运行 Windows 之类的系统，但它们没有那种用于硬件交互的库。所以嵌入式开发在那些设备上并不太可行。如果你只是需要一个 NAS，那么不使用树莓派也能做得很好。但对于所有那些嵌入式硬件项目来说，它确实是最好的入门工具。所以，是的，我很兴奋。
The Raspberry Pi, I hope they sort of figure out the shortage. There's some stuff floating around, too, with these new RISC-V boards or RISC-V. I don't know actually how you say it, but. I think it's five. Yeah. Is it five? Okay. RISC-V boards and stuff too.
我希望树莓派能解决短缺问题。现在市面上也出现了一些关于 RISC-V 开发板的消息。我其实不知道该怎么读它，但是……我想是“五”（Five）。是“五”吗？好的。RISC-V 开发板之类的东西。
So I'm hopeful there'll be more of this like medium embedded space where it's running an OS, you know, like Linux, but still has this like really nice hardware, I2C, SPI connect a little monitor to it i think that's a it's a great space yeah totally you know one thing i'm surprised is that unlike um arduino which is just full of uh aftermarket you know version like you can get an elegoo arduino uno or like there's a million different companies that are making just following the spec in the case ofduino uno or like there's a million different companies that are making just following the spec in the case of raspberry pi there's there's really nobody who there's there's no company producing raspberry pi at least that i know of uh you know much cheaper i mean i think it's the soc so the the arduino used a pretty ubiquitous chip for its processor it was like a i think a pick
所以我希望会有更多这种中等嵌入式空间的产品，它们运行像 Linux 这样的操作系统，但仍然拥有非常好的硬件接口，比如 I2C、SPI，可以连接小显示器。我认为这是一个很棒的领域。是的，完全同意。你知道，让我惊讶的一点是，不像 Arduino 那样充满了售后市场版本，比如你可以买到 Elegoo Arduino Uno，或者有无数公司在遵循规格制造它。而在树莓派的情况下，据我所知，真的没有人，没有公司在生产更便宜的树莓派。我的意思是，我认为这是因为 SoC（片上系统）。Arduino 的处理器使用的是非常通用的芯片，我想是 PIC。
um anyways made by microchip or whatever so it was like a very like common piece but i think the raspberry pi the like processor which is part of why it was so cheap whatever is this sort of they did all the integration work but it was a basically relatively hard to get piece and they managed to negotiate like a good price for it or whatever which is the actual processor that it's running and so i don't i haven't looked at the five yet but i kind of assume it's the same thing it's like uh economies of scale and it's like not a ubiquitous piece and so the combination makes a little hard to to duplicate yeah that makes sense i do also have an intel knuck which is your mini pc and that's running my nas and all
嗯，不管怎样，是由 Microchip 或其他公司制造的，所以它是一个非常常见的部件。但我认为树莓派的处理器——这也是它之所以便宜的部分原因——是他们完成了所有的集成工作，但它基本上是一个相对难以获得的部件，而他们设法为它谈到了一个好价格。这就是它运行的实际处理器。所以我还没研究过“五”，但我假设情况是一样的，就是规模经济，而且它不是一个通用的部件，所以这种组合使得它很难被复制。是的，这说得通。我确实也有一个英特尔 NUC，也就是你的迷你电脑，它在运行我的 NAS 和所有
of that and that is amazing i actually i had some issue where it wouldn't detect my hard drive every now and then um i updated the bios just as a hail mary before buying another one and just saying we're done but actually updating the bios fixed it so uh it was a hail mary pass that actually got a touchdown i guess did you try swapping the sata cables no that would be oh my gosh i broke two sata cables uh this one though the hard drive just plugs right into the knuck so i think okay um but uh but uh um yeah actually a lot of uh weird really esoteric hardware issues lately that seems to be the october trend for me but yeah many pcs are amazing highly recommend them uh really fun they're so cheap now intel was selling them half off for the uh amazon prime day i don't know what they are now but uh prices are very reasonable
那些东西，这太棒了。我其实遇到过一个问题，它偶尔检测不到我的硬盘。我在买新的之前，死马当活马医更新了 BIOS，结果更新 BIOS 竟然修好了它。所以那次“死马当活马医”的尝试竟然成功了。你试过更换 SATA 线吗？没有，那会……天哪，我弄坏了两根 SATA 线。不过这个硬盘是直接插在 NUC 上的，所以我想……好吧。嗯，最近确实有很多奇怪的、非常深奥的硬件问题，这似乎是我十月份的趋势。但迷你电脑真的很棒，强烈推荐，真的很有趣。它们现在太便宜了，英特尔在亚马逊 Prime Day 期间半价出售它们。我不知道现在价格如何，但价格非常合理。
there's also you mentioned aliexpress before i have seen an uptick in the number of like i don't know we call them like like smaller brands they're just brands you would never recognize selling kind of like old intel atom um chips or even celerons or um those kinds of things in that sort of mini pc form factor or even fanless not really again competing for like the hardware embedded stuff which raspberry pi is again if you want to do any of that definitely go raspberry pi or arduino um but yeah for that sort of like nas like home networking kind of stuff yeah there's there's some pretty cool cool options now and like ones that are like usbc powered and
你之前也提到了全球速卖通（AliExpress），我看到了一些小品牌的增长，就是那些你从未听说过的品牌，它们在销售一些旧的英特尔 Atom 芯片，甚至是赛扬（Celeron）芯片，或者那种迷你电脑外形的产品，甚至是无风扇的。同样，它们并不是在和树莓派竞争那些嵌入式硬件需求。如果你想做那些，一定要选树莓派或 Arduino。但对于像 NAS 或家庭网络这类需求，现在确实有一些非常酷的选择，比如那些支持 USB-C 供电的。
oh wow you know so yeah pretty cool that's super neat um all right time for book of the show what's your book patrick oh man you did the good intro and i cut it okay all right my book of the show is is an old one but i've been i've been going back through it uh you know my kids are getting old now whatever so so we've been going through the which is harry potter and the sorcerer's stone but the illustrated edition at some point one of our family members picked this up which is a nice big book like not thick like you know the harry potter books are thick but this is like wide like tall and wide which is just a nice form factor and it has just beautiful illustrations in it uh and so i feel like it's just it's just one of those things you know everyone begs to to be able to see the page instead of instead of just uh just reading it
哦，哇，你知道，所以是的，非常酷，这太棒了。好吧，节目推荐书的时间到了。帕特里克，你推荐什么书？天哪，你做了很好的开场白，而我把它打断了。好吧，好吧，我推荐的书是一本老书，但我一直在重读它。你知道，我的孩子们现在长大了，所以我们一直在读《哈利·波特与魔法石》，但这是插图版。有一次我们的家人买了这个，这是一本漂亮的大书，不是那种厚厚的哈利·波特书，而是又宽又高，外形非常棒，里面有精美的插图。所以我觉得这正是那种每个人都渴望看到页面，而不仅仅是阅读它的书。
so i've been really really enjoying that maybe it's a bit of a cop-out but uh that's what i have reading time's been a little limited so i'm going way in the way back machine to pull up this one uh but but yeah it doesn't ever recommend it if you if you weren't aware that they have illustrated editions or if you have you know i guess that that's a there's an xkcd comic about that like how many people are born each year thus if you say like you know what seven eight nine before you can kind of start getting kids into harry potter like there's you know millions of kids who sort of coming into it so if you have one of those in your life wow your own kid or you know somebody you know anyways looking for a gift idea shout out to this or if you've never read the series yourself i mean i don't think everyone
所以我一直非常非常享受它。也许这有点偷懒，但我现在能读的时间有点有限，所以我用了“时光机”来翻出这一本。但如果你们不知道有插图版，或者如果你们身边有孩子，我想 XKCD 有一幅漫画讲过这个，关于每年有多少孩子出生，所以如果你说七、八、九岁开始让孩子接触哈利·波特，那有数百万孩子正在进入这个世界。所以如果你的生活中也有这样的孩子，或者你自己的孩子，或者你认识的人，总之，如果你在找礼物点子，强烈推荐这个。或者如果你自己从来没读过这个系列，我不认为地球上每个人
on earth has read maybe nearly but not everyone so if you've not read it before this is a great way to to get into that very cool yeah i haven't read the illustrated edition of this but i've read the illustrated edition of uh terry pratchett by the color of magic and uh yeah i'd also read the original color of magic yeah the illustrated edition is amazing it's similar what you said it's a huge it's a very like wide tall book and uh has a lot of beautiful illustrations it's a lot of fun my book of the show is actually a show of the show. It's the Pete and Sebastian show, which is another podcast. You know, there's been so much negativity. And I mean, I know this is almost becoming itself a stereotype, but there's just so much negativity on the news that I just
都读过，可能差不多，但不是每个人都读过。所以如果你以前没读过，这是一个很好的入门方式。太酷了，是的，我没读过这本书的插图版，但我读过特里·普拉切特的《魔法的颜色》的插图版，我也读过原版的《魔法的颜色》。是的，插图版太棒了，和你说的类似，它是一本非常宽大的书，有很多精美的插图，非常有趣。我节目推荐的其实是一个节目。是《皮特和塞巴斯蒂安秀》（The Pete and Sebastian Show），这是另一个播客。你知道，现在有太多的负面情绪了。我知道这几乎快成为一种刻板印象了，但新闻里确实有太多的负面消息，我只是
felt like I needed, you know, something I basically needed something funny, some comedy, something positive and funny, and where I knew that they weren't going to talk about the news. So if you don't want to hear about the news, you should listen to Programming Throwdown. But after you've heard Programming Throwdown, if you still don't want to hear about the news, you should listen to the Pete and Sebastian show.
觉得我需要一些有趣的东西，一些喜剧，一些积极和好笑的东西，而且我知道他们不会谈论新闻。所以如果你不想听新闻，你应该听《Programming Throwdown》。但在听完《Programming Throwdown》之后，如果你还是不想听新闻，你应该听《皮特和塞巴斯蒂安秀》。
Those guys are hilarious. They're right around our age. So, you know, they don't really I don't know if that matters that much. But, you know, some of the references, you know, are of our era. So that part of it is kind of nice, too. But, you know, they're really funny. They riff on each other pretty well. And, you know, it's just like some nice banter
那些家伙太搞笑了。他们和我们年纪差不多。所以，你知道，我不知道这是否重要。但你知道，他们的一些梗是我们那个时代的。所以那部分也挺好的。但你知道，他们真的很有趣。他们互相接梗接得很好，而且，这只是一些很好的闲聊。
to listen what kind of show is it it's basically uh it's it's just a comedy show so what they'll do is they'll show up with three or four topics so for example in the last episode i saw one of the topic was basically vermin uh getting into their. So like raccoons getting into their backyard and things like that. And the way they deal with it and the pest control guy and how does someone get into that career? And just, it's hilarious. I was just dying laughing.
听听看，这是什么节目？它基本上就是一个喜剧节目。他们会带着三四个话题出现。例如，在上一集中，我看到其中一个话题基本上是关于害虫进入他们家。比如浣熊进入他们的后院之类的。他们处理它的方式，还有那个害虫防治人员，以及一个人是怎么进入那个行业的？这太搞笑了。我当时笑得要死。
They also, you know, they're comedians. They have a very infectious laugh. I think that's almost par for the course to be a comedian. It's, yeah, it's a riot highly recommend it um there's there's a bunch of really good comedy podcasts uh i'm sure i didn't stumble on them on patreon but only after you subscribe to our patreon so go to patreon.com slash programming throwdown and please sponsor us support us we really do appreciate it we take that money and ultimately put it to getting more folks to learn about programming. And we're going to take some of it, whatever we have left over, and use it for gifts on the
他们也是喜剧演员。他们的笑声非常有感染力。我认为这几乎是喜剧演员的标配。是的，这太好笑了，强烈推荐。还有很多非常好的喜剧播客。我确定我不是在 Patreon 上偶然发现它们的，只有在你订阅了我们的 Patreon 之后。所以去 patreon.com/programmingthrowdown，请赞助我们，支持我们，我们真的很感激。我们拿这些钱，最终用于让更多人了解编程。我们会拿出一部分，剩下的钱，用来作为
Christmas raffle, which is something we do every year. And it's coming up in a couple of months. So we try and give all of it back to the community, or we do give all of it back to the community in some way, shape, or form. And we try and use it as best we can to get more folks into programming and we really appreciate your support on that i'm going to try to do it jason style it is time for tool of the show that's amazing what's your tool to show patrick uh my tool to show is Obsidian, which is you can find at obsidian.md. This is, I guess you'd call it a note taking app, but it's sort of there's a collection of these. I think there's one called Notion.
圣诞抽奖的奖品，这是我们每年都会做的事情。再过几个月就要到了。所以我们尽量把所有的钱都回馈给社区，或者以某种形式回馈给社区。我们尽量利用它来让更多人参与编程，我们真的很感谢你们的支持。我要试着像杰森那样做，现在是节目推荐工具的时间了。太棒了，帕特里克，你推荐什么工具？嗯，我推荐的工具是 Obsidian，你可以在 obsidian.md 找到它。我想你会称它为笔记应用，但它属于这类应用中的一种。我想有一个叫 Notion 的。
There's Obsidian. And they have phone apps, but also desktop apps. And it's sort of your ability to sort of take notes for yourself, but not just a singular note, multiple notes, but also provide links between them, categorize them and just sort of like organize your sort of thoughts. We've talked about I think I've talked about Google Keep before Google Keep works pretty well, too. But this one is a little bit better for sort of hierarchy and interlinking. And then there's a bunch of, you know, sort of community provided plugins. They do not, they do sell a way to
还有 Obsidian。它们有手机应用，也有桌面应用。它让你能够为自己做笔记，不仅仅是单一的笔记，而是多个笔记，还可以提供它们之间的链接、分类，并整理你的想法。我们之前谈过，我想我之前谈过 Google Keep，Google Keep 也很好用。但这个在层级结构和相互链接方面更好一些。而且还有很多社区提供的插件。他们确实销售一种
synchronize across your devices, but you can also provide your own synchronization. And the nice thing about Obsidian is it's all just text files. So each note is a file and each file is a markdown text file. So that's sort of its strength. And I guess maybe a little bit its weakness. So rather than a lot of companies will do a proprietary database, or even like a SQLite database, a little harder here, if you know, the company shuts down, it's not open source, at least I don't think it's open source. But if the company shuts down, you just have like a directory of text files. So it'd be very straightforward for you to recover that to import it into something else. I know it just feels like if you're going to get invested in something that you're, you know, wanting to use, I feel like it's a really nice take on it.
跨设备同步的方式，但你也可以提供自己的同步。Obsidian 的好处在于它全部只是文本文件。所以每个笔记都是一个文件，每个文件都是一个 Markdown 文本文件。所以这是它的优势。我想也许也是它的一点弱点。很多公司会使用专有数据库，甚至是 SQLite 数据库，这里就比较难了。如果公司倒闭了，它不是开源的，至少我不认为它是开源的。但如果公司倒闭了，你只是拥有一个文本文件目录。所以你恢复它并导入到其他地方会非常简单。我知道，如果你要投入到你想要使用的东西中，我觉得这是一个非常好的选择。
And I'm having something I've been trying to sort of follow a lot of techniques have built up around sort of this organization uh like life operating system and like there's like a lot of these but i and i've been trying to sort of get into it people point out it becomes a trap where you like start trying to like get over organized and making notes itself becomes like a hobby as opposed to just facilitating your thing so i don don't know. I find it very intriguing. I feel like I have this constant to-do list that is in my head and getting more organized is one of those things. So I've been trying out this Obsidian on my phone and then on my desktop as well as a
我一直在尝试遵循围绕这种组织方式建立的许多技术，比如“生活操作系统”，有很多这样的东西。但我一直在尝试进入它，人们指出这会变成一个陷阱，你会开始试图过度组织，让做笔记本身变成一种爱好，而不是为了促进你的事情。所以我不知道。我觉得它非常吸引人。我觉得我脑子里一直有一个待办事项列表，而变得更有条理是其中之一。所以我一直在手机和桌面上尝试这个 Obsidian，作为
way to sort of take notes about what I'm doing, provide like topics, but also link to other notes. And so I've been enjoying it check it out obsidian at obsidian.md very cool yeah so i just looked it up obsidian is not open source but um but you were saying you could sync it like with google drive or something yeah so like i i use an iphone so i am able to use icloud and just like the directory and there's some there's some warnings to be sure like you got to be a little careful but i for instance would can't think of an example where i would be editing on my phone and my desktop at the same time
一种记录我正在做的事情、提供主题，并链接到其他笔记的方式。所以我很喜欢它，去看看 obsidian.md 吧。太酷了，是的，我刚查了一下，Obsidian 不是开源的，但你说你可以用 Google Drive 之类的同步它？是的，我用的是 iPhone，所以我可以使用 iCloud 和那个目录。有一些警告，你需要小心一点，但我举不出一个我会在手机和桌面上同时编辑同一个文件的例子。
this is only for me so the you know sort of synchronization should be pretty straightforward um they do offer like a a sort of uh it not very expensive, a monthly fee if you want to sort of support the developer, but also enable like proper, you know, full featured syncing, which can work. But again, the thing I like is just that you can see it. You can just open it with notepad or whatever VI pointed at the, you know, folder and you can totally see all of your markdown. Yeah, that is awesome.
这只是我一个人用的，所以同步应该非常简单。他们确实提供了一种不太贵的月费，如果你想支持开发者，也可以启用功能齐全的同步。但同样，我喜欢的是你可以看到它。你可以直接用记事本或任何 VI 打开它，指向那个文件夹，你完全可以看到你所有的 Markdown。是的，那太棒了。
That is really cool. I was using, oh, i was using oh i was using workflowy for a while um but uh but yeah like kind of like what you said you know i found myself spending more time writing things in workflowy i ended up switching to uh when i got this remarkable i ended up switching to just writing everything on the tablet. But yeah, I do think having the right note-taking app is really important. It kind of reduces that cognitive load we were just talking about.
那真的很酷。我以前用过 Workflowy，但就像你说的，我发现自己花在 Workflowy 上写东西的时间更多了。当我有了这个 Remarkable 平板电脑后，我转而直接在平板上写所有东西。但确实，拥有正确的笔记应用非常重要。它在某种程度上减轻了我们刚才谈到的认知负荷。
Because once you write it down, it doesn't have to be in your head anymore, as long as you're willing to look at it every now and then. My tool of the show is Ink by Inkle. So I've talked about... Actually, I think, know i've talked about actually i think patrick you talked about the 80 the 80 days or maybe i've always been the one anyways uh inkle is this company that makes a bunch of interactive fiction books there's i think it's called 80 days around the
因为一旦你把它写下来，它就不必再留在你的脑子里了，只要你愿意偶尔看一眼。我节目推荐的工具是 Inkle 的 Ink。所以我谈过……其实我想，我知道我谈过，其实我想帕特里克你谈过《80 天环游世界》或者可能一直是我。不管怎样，Inkle 是一家制作许多互动小说书的公司，我想是叫《80 天环游世界》。
world oh okay um and then there's overboard which is by the same company and a bunch of folks so they released their i don't want to say engine but they're they're basically system for creating these text-based games and it has like a nice markup and everything um they open sourced it and um it's a scripting language is what they call it um it has a has like a nice template style where you can kind of uh you know mad lib different things into it um and the reason this came up was i guess people have been porting it to other game engines so they recently ported it to unreal i think someone's working on a port to godot or getting it to compile with godot um but yeah i thought that was pretty neat um it looks really fun if you want to create a
哦，好的。然后还有《Overboard》，是同一家公司制作的。他们发布了他们的——我不想说是引擎，但基本上是创建这些文字游戏的系统。它有一个很好的标记语言等等。他们开源了它，它是一种脚本语言，这就是他们所说的。它有一个很好的模板样式，你可以把不同的东西填进去。人们一直在把它移植到其他游戏引擎，所以他们最近把它移植到了 Unreal，我想有人正在做 Godot 的移植，或者让它能用 Godot 编译。但是的，我觉得这很酷。如果你想创建一个
you know an interactive game similar to the ones that ankle has made um definitely check it out i think it's a really neat tool oh very cool all right something else getting pushed into my queue. Okay. It goes on your obsidian. Yeah. Hang on. I'm going to write it down. I'm going to link. All right. I think with that, it is time to talk about our topic of the show, which is Godot. Yeah, Patrick. So you haven't tried Godot yet, right? No, I haven't. I've kind of watched the tutorials read the stuff I'm familiar with the the system been tracking it for for quite a while but it
互动游戏，类似于 Inkle 制作的那些，一定要去看看，我认为这是一个非常好的工具。哦，太酷了，好吧，又有东西要加入我的队列了。好的，它会进入你的 Obsidian。是的，等等，我要把它写下来。我要链接它。好吧，我想是时候谈谈我们节目的主题了，也就是 Godot。是的，帕特里克。所以你还没试过 Godot，对吧？不，我还没试过。我看了教程，读了相关资料，我对这个系统很熟悉，也关注它很久了，但它
yeah writing a game in Godot is like again one of those things in my queue I haven't managed to pop it out just yet yeah I mean my experience with Godot was um you know I had this ai hero game i talked about on earlier episode and originally that was written in phaser which was a javascript um library and phaser i guess phaser is technically a game engine but um the thing about phaser is you know it basically gives you all the libraries like here's a graphics library here's a physics library but you still have to kind of code all the game up yourself and where i got stuck was on the sort of way to be an efficient game development you know engineer like for example imagine if you had a bug at the boss of your game and the only way you could fix the bug is by playing through the entire game,
在 Godot 中写游戏也是我队列中的事情之一，我还没来得及把它拿出来。是的，我使用 Godot 的经验是……你知道，我有一个我在之前节目中谈到的 AI 英雄游戏，最初是用 Phaser 编写的，那是一个 JavaScript 库。Phaser 我想技术上是一个游戏引擎，但 Phaser 的问题是，它基本上给了你所有的库，比如这里有一个图形库，这里有一个物理库，但你仍然必须自己编写所有的游戏代码。我卡住的地方在于如何成为一名高效的游戏开发工程师。例如，想象一下如果你的游戏 Boss 有一个 Bug，而修复这个 Bug 的唯一方法是玩完整个游戏，
getting to the boss and then trying to recreate the bug. Well, it'd be super frustrating, right? It'd take you hours and hours to encounter the bug and all of that. Now that's a pretty extreme example. But if you break that down, you can kind of end up in a situation where it's really time consuming and difficult to debug anything.
到达 Boss 那里，然后尝试重现这个 Bug。好吧，那会非常令人沮丧，对吧？你需要花费数小时才能遇到这个 Bug。这只是一个极端的例子。但如果你把它拆解开来，你最终可能会陷入一种调试任何东西都非常耗时且困难的情况。
And actually, even more than debugging, you really have to, a friend put it really nicely, find the fun. When you first make a game, unless you're just re-skinning another game and keeping the mechanics identical, when you create a game originally it's it's not very fun at least none of the ones i made were very fun and um for ai hero you know the original concept of the game was where where you would sort of bring your own shapes like it's like oh i need a circle here oh i need a line here i need a curve here and and you'd sort of draw from this toolbox of shapes and um that ended up not being very fun because you know if you got it wrong it was really frustrating or like often the more complex
其实，比起调试，你真的必须——一位朋友说得很好——找到乐趣。当你第一次制作游戏时，除非你只是给另一个游戏换皮并保持机制不变，否则当你最初创建一个游戏时，它并不是很有趣。至少我做的那些都不怎么有趣。对于 AI 英雄，游戏的最初概念是你自己带形状，比如“哦，我这里需要一个圆，我这里需要一条线，我这里需要一条曲线”，你会从这个形状工具箱中提取。这最终变得不怎么有趣，因为如果你弄错了，会非常令人沮丧。或者通常更复杂的
shape like a curve could do anything a line could do right so you just always pick the curve and it got to this point where it yeah it wasn't very fun and um i couldn't really iterate quicker quickly because of what we just talked about and so i got stuck and so i put it down um when i ported it to godot you know obviously it still wasn't fun because i just straight ported it to godot exactly as it was but i could um you know and we'll talk about this when we talk about godot but i could go into specific parts of the puzzle and just play that part in isolation or just look at a certain curve in isolation and play around with it and eventually that was what allowed me to find the fun in that game um so so that was my experience with godot and overall i'm a i'm a big
形状，比如曲线，可以做直线能做的任何事情，对吧？所以你总是选择曲线，结果它变得一点也不好玩。我无法快速迭代，因为我们刚才谈到的原因，所以我卡住了，于是我放弃了。当我把它移植到 Godot 时，显然它仍然不好玩，因为我只是把它原封不动地移植到了 Godot。但我可以……我们谈到 Godot 时会讨论这个……我可以进入谜题的特定部分，单独玩那一部分，或者单独看某条曲线并摆弄它。最终，这让我找到了那个游戏的乐趣。所以这就是我使用 Godot 的经验，总的来说，我是一个大粉丝。
fan i think game engines and maybe it sort of changed today but i think like this example like you're saying jason there's nothing that could have like you're a capable programmer you could have uh coded all of this yourself right so the things we're going to talk about that are like the components of a game engine it's it's really like a almost like a menu and many game engines are pretty flexible and that they like let you order stuff off the menu but you can also kind of like sub in your own thing and i think some people get into any you kind of see uh post mortems or whatever get into their own like i'm just going to build my own game engine or i'm building something so different or so off nominally like the expected path that i'm going to start by building my game engine and they just never finish building the game engine and you just sort of get into this you know sort of thing and i think like you know it is it's like programming language
我认为游戏引擎，也许今天有所改变，但就像你说的杰森，没有什么能像……你是一个有能力的程序员，你可以自己编写所有这些代码，对吧？所以我们要谈论的那些作为游戏引擎组件的东西，它真的就像一个菜单。许多游戏引擎非常灵活，它们让你从菜单中点菜，但你也可以替换成你自己的东西。我认为有些人会陷入……你会在事后分析中看到……陷入“我要构建自己的游戏引擎”或者“我正在构建一些非常不同或非常偏离预期路径的东西”，以至于我从构建游戏引擎开始，结果他们永远没能完成游戏，你只是陷入了那种事情。我认为这就像编程语言
choice in a way which is that you know probably there are many ways to solve it and for every person in every situation it's just going to be you know going to pick one and and hope for the best but i think like starting with that basic game loop right where uh unlike most applications at least that i write you know they sort of start they do some processing and then they end that's not how a game works. A game doesn't, I mean, I guess at some high level, you exit the game, but you get into this loop, right? And so just setting up the loop and forcing, like you were saying, to get into the process of rapidly testing and getting to the part where you have a sort of working prototype
的选择，在某种程度上，有很多方法可以解决它，对于每个人在每种情况下，你只需要选择一个并祈祷最好。但我认为从那个基本游戏循环开始，不像我写的大多数应用程序，它们开始、处理一些数据然后结束，游戏不是这样工作的。游戏不会……我的意思是，在某种高层面上，你退出游戏，但你进入了这个循环，对吧？所以设置这个循环并强制，就像你说的，进入快速测试的过程，并尽快到达拥有一个可运行原型的部分，
somewhat as quickly as possible also helps with the motivation. And I think that gets underestimated that like having something that's a demoable and you know playable and sort of excites you helps you stick with it yeah you're totally right um i mean think about like some of the really iconic games um and uh i'm going to sort of date myself here but like super mario 3 for example on nintendo there was one level where you got this boot and the boot would let you walk over spikes you could jump really high you could like step on things and and kill them that you know you couldn't without the boot it just radically
也有助于动力。我认为这被低估了，拥有一个可演示、可玩且让你兴奋的东西有助于你坚持下去。是的，你说得完全对。想想一些非常标志性的游戏，我要暴露我的年龄了，比如任天堂上的《超级马里奥 3》，有一关你得到了这个靴子，靴子让你可以在尖刺上行走，你可以跳得很高，你可以踩在敌人身上并杀死它们，没有靴子你做不到。它彻底
changed the game and and there was only one level where you had the boot and that level was kind of designed around the boot um you know there's just a lot of spikes that you wouldn't be able to survive otherwise and stuff like that um and so yeah i mean you know the game developers and designers you know they had an idea and they tested that idea and they built a whole level around that idea and then when you fast forward to modern mario games you know i play uh what is it called the one on the switch where four people could play and only one person needs to win is oh yeah that's right super mario 3d um what i find when i play these games is basically almost every level kind of has some kind of trick to it or something kind of unique
改变了游戏，而且只有一关你有靴子，那一关是围绕靴子设计的。你知道，有很多尖刺，否则你无法生存。所以是的，游戏开发者和设计师，他们有一个想法，他们测试了这个想法，并围绕这个想法构建了整个关卡。当你快进到现代马里奥游戏时，我玩那个 Switch 上的游戏，四个人可以玩，只需要一个人赢，哦，对了，是《超级马里奥 3D 世界》。我玩这些游戏时发现，基本上每个关卡都有某种技巧或独特之处，
like one level will have you know platforms that flip over when you jump on them another level will have you know something else and so and so you have to be able to test all these concepts uh independently and very quickly and game engines are really really good at doing that i don't i think we talked about unity briefly before but since then i've read the masters of doom uh which i think we had at a book a show before which is basically how john romero and john carmack uh kind of started their game studio and how they sort of evolved it and you know i think one of the things through through that that that sort of impacted me is the sort of separation of concerns,
比如一个关卡会有当你跳上去时会翻转的平台，另一个关卡会有别的东西。所以你必须能够独立且非常快速地测试所有这些概念，而游戏引擎非常擅长做这些。我不认为我们之前简要谈过 Unity，但从那以后我读了《Doom 启示录》（Masters of Doom），我想我们之前在节目推荐中提到过，它基本上讲述了约翰·罗梅罗和约翰·卡马克是如何创办他们的游戏工作室以及他们是如何演变的。我认为其中一件事对我影响很大，那就是职责分离，
I guess you'll call it, which is John Romero just had this ability to create levels and interesting mechanics, like you were saying. And John Carmack would focus, I hope I'm getting this right. I think I'm getting it right. John Carmack is like very specifically
我想你会这么称呼它，约翰·罗梅罗有能力创造关卡和有趣的机制，就像你说的。而约翰·卡马克会专注于，我希望我没记错。我想我没记错。约翰·卡马克非常专注于
on like at the time, the limited hardware, right? And sort of saying, how do I optimize rendering a 3d scene so think about like wolfenstein 3d or eventually doom like how do i get the levels encoded textured blitted onto the screen so that you know john carmack can kind of push the engine and and sort of work the fun and i think you know talking about you know we're talking about good dough here and tries to give you that same separation of concern. Like you focus on the half of creating with the tools, like Jason is saying,
当时有限的硬件，对吧？并说，我如何优化 3D 场景的渲染？想想《德军总部 3D》或最终的《Doom》，我如何将关卡编码、贴图、位块传输到屏幕上，以便约翰·卡马克可以推动引擎并发挥乐趣。我认为，我们在这里谈论 Godot，它试图给你同样的职责分离。你专注于使用工具进行创作，就像杰森说的，机制和有趣的部分是他们无法提供给你的，你必须自己带来。是的，你刚才说到了你之前说的，回到那个话题，我参加了很多视频游戏开发聚会。如果你在奥斯汀，你参加其中一个，你可能会在某个时候遇到我。很多时候我看到人们
the mechanics and the interesting bits is the part that they're, they're not really going to be able to provide you that you got to, you got to bring that yourself. Yeah. And you're getting to what you were saying earlier, just circling back to that, you know, I go to a lot of video game development meetups. Like if you're in austin and you're at one of these you probably run into me at some point and um a lot of the time i see people
拥有一个非常有趣的游戏引擎，但没有乐趣，没有乐趣在里面。例如，我最近看到一个，它是像《我的世界》那样的引擎，全是体素，但你有一个像蜘蛛侠那样的抓钩，所以你可以在关卡中摆荡，你还有可以炸出大坑的火箭。有了这两者，你实际上可以挖掘隧道或从地下挖出来。摆荡在关卡中并在地上挖洞是一种乐趣，但这只是一个引擎，对吧？没有乐趣在里面。我认为，也许最好是在 Godot 中构建它，即使你每秒只有 5 帧。
who have a really interesting game engine um but then there's there's no fun it's not there's no fun there so for example i saw one recently where it was like minecraft uh you know the engine was like minecraft where it's all voxels um but you had a grappling hook kind of like spider-man's web web fingers right so you could swing around the level and then you also had these rockets that could just blow big craters in the level and with the two of of them, you could actually, you know, dig tunnels or dig up from the ground. And it, it was like a joy to swing around the levels and put holes in the ground, but it was, it was just an engine, right? Like there was, there was no fun there. And, um, and I think that, you know, it might be better to have, let's say, built that in Godot, even if you're getting five frames per second or something.
但你可以弄清楚乐趣是什么。我可以在这个游戏中添加什么让它变得非常有趣？然后如果你必须重写它，那也没关系，因为在那时你已经完成了快速原型设计，并且已经找到了乐趣，现在你只需要重新编码。这样做可能比开始构建自己的引擎更好，最终得到两个游戏副本。所以也许这是一个很好的过渡，至少我会强行过渡，什么是游戏引擎，特别是 Godot 的版本。我认为谈论通用性，我们已经提到了执行循环，在其中你会有阶段，其中一个阶段是输入处理，是的，每个人都可以自己编写，
But you could figure out what the fun is. What can I add to this game to make it really fun? And then if you have to rewrite it, it's fine, because at that point you've done the rapid prototyping and you've sort of found the fun, and now you just have to recode it it's probably better to do that and end up with two copies of your game than to start building your own engine so maybe maybe that's a good segue where at least i'll force it is uh like what what gig game engine is and then specifically godot's kind of version i think talking generically we already mentioned i already mentioned the the sort of loop the sort of execution loop and in that you're going to have stages and one of those stages is going to be input handling which yes everyone could write
但你真的不想这样做，比如如何处理键盘输入、同时按下的多个键、鼠标点击等等。还有一些东西，比如你想在屏幕上制作一个菜单，我们上次谈到了桌面 UI，我们提到了游戏 UI，但你真的不想从零开始编写窗口系统或菜单系统。所以他们也会带来这些东西。是的，完全同意。而且他们会以跨平台的方式来做。
themselves but you really don't want to which is how do you handle keyboard input multiple keys pressed down at the same time mouse input clicks and you know all of that kind of like input handling as well as like just some of the stuff that, you know, hey, you want to make a menu on the screen, we talked about, I think it was last time, right about desktop UIs. And we were, we were alluding to game UIs, but you really don't want to write a windowing system or a menu system, you know, from from scratch. And so they're going to bring that kind of stuff as well. Yeah, totally, totally. And they're going to do it in a way that is cross-platform.
所以在我的例子中，当我使用 JavaScript 游戏引擎时，他们有一种在手机上运行它的方法。这有点超出我的能力范围，所以我不会尝试解释它是如何工作的。但当我切换到 Godot 时，这是我非常想确保的一件事。因为虽然我在电脑上进行游戏测试和开发，但我的意图是让几乎每个人都在手机上玩这个游戏。所以类似于如果你在做树莓派或 Arduino 的东西，你必须进行交叉编译，对吧？你必须让你做的任何东西在那个架构上工作。
So in my case, when I use the JavaScript game engine, they had a way of running it on the phone. And this is a little bit beyond me, so I'm not going to try and explain how that works. But then when I switched to Godot, that was one of the things that I really wanted to make sure. Because although I was playtesting and developing on my computer, my intent was for almost everybody to play this on their phone. And so similar to if you're doing Raspberry Pi or Arduino stuff, you have to kind of cross-compile, right? And you have to make whatever you're doing work in that other architecture.
而且可能会有各种各样的小问题。所以 Godot 有一种很好的方式，说“好的，你可以在电脑上使用鼠标，或者在手机上使用触摸屏”。他们有一种 API 可以处理所有这些。我甚至没想过这一点。所以是的，我想我们一直在回避那个大问题，也就是实际的渲染引擎，我想这可能是大多数人首先想到的他们不想
And there could be all sorts of little nits there. And so Godot has this nice way of saying, okay, you can use your mouse on your computer or you can use the touchscreen on your phone. And they sort of like have one api that can kind of handle all of that i didn't even think about that so yeah i guess we've been dodging the the big one though which is also just the actual kind of rendering engine which i think is what all probably most people think about first as the thing they don't want
自己解决的事情。没有人想直接用 OpenGL 编写，虽然你可以。现在我想那个关于跨平台和可移植性的故事，在 DirectX、OpenGL 和着色器方面可能有点不同。所以他们会提供推送 3D 或 2D 资产的能力，比如精灵、粒子效果、你加载的模型或精灵表，然后处理像绑定和动画之类的事情。他们会制定好文件格式，甚至还有这些东西的编辑器。所以不仅仅是“我在脚本文件中手动编写所有这些东西”，这可能有效，但你如何与想要为你的游戏做出贡献的其他人合作，
to go solve themselves um no one wants to write directly in open gl although you can um and now i guess that story again to your your cross-platform and portability is is probably a bit of a different story with direct x and open gl and shaders and you know so they're going to provide that ability to push 3d or 2d assets which would be like sprites particle effects models that you load or sprite sheets if you're if you're doing sort of sprites and push those through and then handling things like rigging and animation and they're going to have sort of file formats worked out and even in the case of like editors for that stuff as well so so not just oh i'm in a script file like you know writing all this stuff by hand which may work but how would you join with someone else who wants to contribute to your game
并说“嘿，听着，为什么你不负责调整奔跑动画？”这里有编辑器，这里有关键帧，允许你弄清楚这些东西。是的，完全同意。老实说，直到今天我也不知道安卓或 iOS 上的硬件图形加速是如何工作的。我不知道它们是否都使用相同的东西，或者是否有两个不同的东西，Godot 是否必须写两次。我的意思是，Godot 系统或 Unity 或任何这些引擎都在为你处理所有这些。所以你在电脑上运行它，它甚至可能是 OpenGL 或 DirectX。我也不知道，因为 Godot 在处理所有这些。
and say hey listen like why don't you handle tweaking the run animation um and you know here's the editor and here's the keyframes and you know allow you to figure out that kind of stuff yeah totally i mean i honestly to this day i have no idea how how the hardware you know graphics acceleration stuff uh works on android or ios i don't know if they both use the same thing or if there's two different ones and godot had to write everything twice um i mean the godot system or unity or any of these is is handling all of that for you so So you run it on your computer, which it could even be OpenGL or DirectX. I don't know that either because Godot is handling all of that.
然后当你在手机上运行它时，它就能工作，他们尽了最大努力确保你在所有这些不同的设备上获得完全相同的体验，如果你仔细想想，这真的很了不起。这其中的另一部分是编辑器。编辑器非常重要。Phaser 和其他游戏引擎没有开发环境，它们是一组库，你注定要在其中编写游戏。但 Godot 自带一个编辑器，编辑器也是用 Godot 编写的，这很有趣。它表明它确实可以用于某些事情。但编辑器很漂亮。你拖放不同的精灵或声音，它会处理定位音频等等。然后你也可以做……所以编辑器给你场景，例如，我的一个场景。
And then when you run it on the phone, it just works and they've done their best to make sure you get exactly the same experience on all these different devices, which is actually really remarkable if you think about it. Another piece of this is the editor the editor is extremely important um you know phaser and these other game engines they don't they don't have a
当你在手机上运行它时，它就能直接工作。他们尽了最大努力确保你在所有这些不同的设备上获得完全相同的体验，如果你仔细想想，这真的很了不起。这其中的另一个部分是编辑器，编辑器非常重要。你知道，Phaser和其他游戏引擎，它们没有一个
development environment they're a set of libraries and you're meant to write your game in them but but you know godot comes with a editor the editor is also written in Godot, which is kind of interesting. It shows that it actually works for something. But the editor is beautiful. And you drag and drop different sprites or sounds, and it'll do positional audio and all of that. And then you can also do... So the editor gives you scenes so for example you know one of my scenes
开发环境。它们只是一组库，你需要用它们来编写游戏。但Godot自带一个编辑器，而且这个编辑器本身也是用Godot编写的，这很有趣，说明它确实能胜任某些工作。这个编辑器很漂亮，你可以拖放不同的精灵或声音，它还能处理定位音频等等。你还可以……编辑器为你提供了场景，例如，你知道我的一个场景
in my game is the main menu and there's a bunch of little boxes like hit boxes that you could click on for the different options of the menu and all of that but then they have a recursive the scenes are recursive so you can actually for example um you know each level of my game had a scene for each line so your point of the game is you're drawing these lines to kind of uh uh separate different groups of dots. And each line is a sub-scene. And so you can actually drill into the line scene and you can manipulate a single line. And when you click the button, it should grow a little bit to like acknowledge
在我的游戏中，主菜单里有一堆小方块，也就是点击区域，你可以点击它们来选择菜单中的不同选项。而且这些场景是递归的，所以实际上，举个例子，我游戏中的每一关都有一个对应每一行的场景。游戏的重点是你需要画这些线来把不同组的点分开。每一行都是一个子场景。所以你实际上可以深入到线条场景中，去操作单条线。当你点击按钮时，它应该稍微变大一点，以确认
that you've tapped the button and everything. And you can test all of that in isolation very, very quickly. And then when you are comfortable then you can spiral back out and test the larger scene um there's some things you'll have to contend with so for example you know if you're testing the line scene by itself then you've never loaded a level and so if you you know like one of the issues I ran into was when I'm testing the line scene, I would drag the line and then it would crash because it would see, oh, did the player solve the level with the, where the line is now?
你已经点击了按钮之类的操作。你可以非常非常快地单独测试所有这些功能。当你觉得没问题了，就可以退回到上一层，测试更大的场景。当然，你得处理一些问题，比如如果你单独测试线条场景，你并没有加载关卡，所以你遇到的问题之一就是，当我测试线条场景时，我会拖动线条，然后它就会崩溃，因为它会检测：“哦，玩家现在把线放在这里，关卡解开了吗？”
And there is no level. So you have to deal with that. But what you get in exchange is the ability to test each of these different components. And I found that to be really the thing that got the game across the finish line so other things that that i think time with editor are you know as jason's already mentioning with the scenes but often uh many games have levels um and for levels you need some sort of map or you know yeah sort of environment and so having the ability to do that is something i i remember i guess that was like unreal tournament or something way back in
但这里并没有关卡。所以你必须处理这种情况。但作为交换，你获得的是测试每一个独立组件的能力。我发现这正是让游戏最终完成的关键。我认为还有一些与编辑器相关的事情，正如杰森刚才提到的场景，但通常许多游戏都有关卡，而对于关卡，你需要某种地图或者环境，所以拥有这种能力是我记得的，我想那应该是《虚幻竞技场》之类的，很久以前
the day came with or no it was half-life i remember had an editor and you could download the editor and you could like make your own oh yeah levels it's called like hammer or something i don't remember i'll have to look it up now but you know people started shipping that hey listen like anyone can kind of create their own own level here uh and you know it's just a way of defining it but again this is something that sort of i guess i overused the python thing batteries included that when you want to go build a level here's a way to allow others to build levels for your game um so if you're you know building a logic puzzler or jason was just member uh mentioning uh the inkle stuff and sort of like hey they built a robust way for even others to reuse their approach and so so being able to kind of have the level editing and sort of either 2d
那时候自带的，或者不，是《半条命》，我记得它有一个编辑器，你可以下载这个编辑器，然后你可以制作自己的……哦对，关卡，它叫“Hammer”还是什么的，我不记得了，我得查一下。但你知道，人们开始发布它，说“嘿，听着，任何人都可以创建自己的关卡”，这只是一种定义方式。但同样，这又是我过度使用 Python 那种“内置电池”理念的地方，当你想要构建一个关卡时，这是一种允许其他人为你的游戏构建关卡的方法。所以如果你正在构建一个逻辑解谜游戏，或者杰森刚才提到的 Inkle 的东西，他们构建了一种强大的方式，让其他人也能复用他们的方法。所以能够拥有关卡编辑功能，无论是 2D
or 3d sort of be be included as a as another a good separation of concerns to allow other people to build out those pieces while you're focusing on maybe some of the mechanics yeah totally it was valves hammer editor and uh i remember uh playing with that too that was a blast another one i played a lot with was um the starcraft editor starcraft one had this amazing editor um and you could actually take the maps you made and play them with your friends on battle.net and they would download the map from you and they joined the the game and everything um but uh um but yeah you know there is nothing more demotivating than like you know you edit a json file and then it takes like three minutes
还是 3D，作为另一种良好的关注点分离，让其他人可以构建这些部分，而你则专注于某些机制，这真的很棒。完全正确，那是 Valve 的 Hammer 编辑器，我记得我也玩过那个，太好玩了。我玩得很多的另一个是《星际争霸》编辑器，《星际争霸 1》有一个很棒的编辑器，你可以把你制作的地图拿去在 Battle.net 上和朋友一起玩，他们会从你这里下载地图，然后加入游戏等等。但是，你知道，没有什么比这更让人沮丧的了：你编辑了一个 JSON 文件，然后它需要三分钟
to compile and then you join you know you start the game you have to click new game you have to choose your character you do all that you have to like skip to the right level and then oh the json file was wrong the level is like unplayable and you have to do the whole thing over again right and so um yeah when people say they're going to build their own game engine i think a lot of them the level's like unplayable and you have to do the whole thing over again. Right. And so, um, yeah, when people say they're going to build their own game engine, I think a lot of them think about, you know,
来编译，然后你加入游戏，你必须点击“新游戏”，选择角色，做完所有这些，你必须跳到正确的关卡，然后“哦，JSON 文件错了，关卡无法游玩”，你必须从头再来。所以，当人们说他们要构建自己的游戏引擎时，我想他们很多人都在想，
what, what, what do I want the engine to do? Uh, uh, you know, to, to like to render or to play,
我想要引擎做什么？是渲染还是播放？
like, what does, what do I want the engine to do for the player? That's usually what people think about, but what you really need to think about is what can the engine do for me to make me as a developer you know 100x more productive especially if you're a solo or a small group or you're doing a one of these game jams or you only have three days you really need the editor to do so much for you the i think i just make like put two and two together maybe i'm wrong i'll have i'd have to
我想要引擎为玩家做什么？这通常是人们想的，但你真正需要考虑的是，引擎能为我做什么，让我作为开发者效率提高 100 倍？特别是如果你是单人开发者、小团队，或者参加游戏开发马拉松（Game Jam），只有三天时间，你真的需要编辑器为你做很多事情。我想我刚才把这两点联系起来了，也许我错了，我得
look i think there's been like a uh uprising a resurgence uh increase in people doing procedural games um in part well we should talk about that we have that perpetually on our list um but something like wave wave function collapse uh and other uh perlin noise and these kinds of things for doing procedural generation. You mentioned Minecraft, right? Kind of famously does this, but other even more elaborate games as well, trying to sort of do every game is unique, you know, or a little different, but there's rules that are obeyed to make sure it's sort of still playable. And I think some of that, not all of it, of course, very fun game mechanic, right? And sort of almost adds that infinite replayability if you
查一下。我认为程序化生成游戏出现了一股热潮，部分原因是——我们应该谈谈这个，我们的列表中一直有这个话题——比如“波函数坍缩”（Wave Function Collapse）、柏林噪声（Perlin noise）以及这类用于程序化生成的算法。你提到了《我的世界》，对吧？它在这方面很有名，但还有其他更复杂的游戏也在尝试，试图让每个游戏都独一无二，或者略有不同，但它们遵循一定的规则以确保游戏仍然可玩。我认为其中一些，当然不是全部，是非常有趣的游戏机制，它几乎增加了无限的可重玩性，如果
can make it fun, but also gets you out of having to build levels right so i think there's this temptation to for some of those games to say well i don't have to sit down and design a fun level like i'm just going to work on an algorithm and if it's not fun the person will just regenerate you know the world or we'll just do something again and it's you know i i think can be not not always but i think it can start to be a little bit of a, of a crutch because someone just saying like, Hey, it's kind of more fun to work on an algorithm to make levels than to actually sit down and make levels. If you're sort of a programmer by, by trade or by inclination, um, some of that sort of artistic
你能让它变得有趣的话。但这也能让你不必去手动构建关卡。所以我认为对于某些游戏来说，有一种诱惑，就是说：“我不必坐下来设计一个有趣的关卡，我只需要研究算法，如果不好玩，玩家就会重新生成世界，或者我们再做一次。”我认为这有时会成为一种拐杖，因为有人会觉得研究算法来生成关卡比真正坐下来制作关卡更有趣。如果你是一个程序员，或者倾向于编程，那么那种艺术性的
crafting and designing the, the sort of perfect one. And I think that's interesting. We were talking about, I think I mentioned last episode or two episodes ago about Factorio, but interesting. I was thinking about this. There's another game, Satisfactory, which is sort of similar to Factorio. And interestingly in Satisfactory, the game, the map is actually static. So they have one map and they've sort of over time, they want to add new features. And so they have to like tell you, hey, when we do this upgrade, this portion of the map warning, like if you're building something elaborate here, you won't really be able to upgrade because this portion is going to change.
创作和设计完美的关卡可能就没那么吸引人了。我觉得这很有趣。我记得上一集或两集前提到过《异星工厂》（Factorio），但我还在想这个。还有另一个游戏叫《幸福工厂》（Satisfactory），它和《异星工厂》有点像。有趣的是，在《幸福工厂》中，地图实际上是静态的。他们只有一张地图，随着时间的推移，他们想添加新功能。所以他们必须告诉你：“嘿，当我们进行这次升级时，地图的这一部分会有警告，如果你在这里建造了复杂的东西，你可能无法升级，因为这一部分会改变。”
Like we want to change this portion of the map versus something like, you know, Victoria, whatever, like you're playing on your seed, you're playing on your specific incarnation. So stuff can be added but you wouldn't really see it unless you regenerated so the same like minecraft and minecraft added a new biome right like you wouldn't see that new biome unless you sort of regenerated uh and so there's this interesting dichotomy between like a static map and uh you know designed and uh procedurally generated one yeah totally i think that there's this, it's another one of these traps,
就像我们想改变地图的这一部分，而不是像《异星工厂》那样，你在你的种子地图上玩，你在你特定的化身中玩。所以东西可以被添加，但除非你重新生成，否则你不会看到它。就像《我的世界》添加了新的生物群系，除非你重新生成，否则你不会看到那个新生物群系。所以静态地图和程序化生成地图之间存在着有趣的二分法。是的，完全同意，我认为这是另一个陷阱，
kind of like building your own engine. But there's this trap where you think that, oh, I'm going to make a sandbox, I think is what they're called. I'm going to make a sandbox game where I'm just going to throw a bunch of mechanics together. And that way I get to do all the fun stuff
有点像构建自己的引擎。但有一个陷阱是，你认为“哦，我要做一个沙盒游戏”，我想是这么叫的。我要做一个沙盒游戏，我只需要把一堆机制扔在一起。这样我就能做所有有趣的事情，
without having to do things i think is not very fun like designing levels or having very scripted situations right and and actually it's really really really hard to make a sandbox game um there's a few of them um they've gotten kind of a cult following um you know i mean other than minecraft i mean minecraft is is kind of like the michael jordan or the beatles or whatever it's kind of like its own entity right but if you take away minecraft you know the sandbox games like like x4 for example or um gary's um gary's mod's a good one um you know a lot of them you know they're just very hard to pull off and so i would suggest to folks who are making their first game um you know make something
而不必做那些我认为不太有趣的事情，比如设计关卡或进行高度脚本化的场景。实际上，制作沙盒游戏真的非常非常难。有几个游戏做到了，它们拥有某种狂热的追随者。除了《我的世界》，《我的世界》就像是迈克尔·乔丹或披头士乐队，它是一个独立的存在。但如果你抛开《我的世界》，你知道的沙盒游戏，比如《X4》或者《盖瑞模组》（Garry's Mod），它们很多都很难成功。所以我建议那些制作第一款游戏的开发者，制作一些
that has like pretty well defined levels where you can just reduce the the scope it turns out making things more complex is very easy but making things fun uh is like for example in mario you know what i at least what i think we're getting into sort of like uh really subjective territory here but i think what's fun about mario is that you have all these very simple systems like the goomba is very simple the little like fireball that spins you know the what do you call that thing you know i'm talking about the wall of fire that no it's not a ball oh the rotating arm of fire yeah yeah the rotating arm of fireballs so so all of these things all the speed runners are really mad at us right now yeah i know we're gonna get email there's gonna be discord and discord over this. Um, is, you know,
有定义明确的关卡的游戏，你可以缩小范围。事实证明，让事情变得复杂很容易，但让事情变得有趣很难。例如在《马力欧》中，我认为我们进入了非常主观的领域，但我认为《马力欧》有趣的地方在于，你拥有所有这些非常简单的系统。比如板栗仔（Goomba）非常简单，那个旋转的小火球，你管那个叫什么？你知道我在说什么吗？那个火墙，不，不是球，哦，旋转的火球臂。是的，旋转的火球臂。所以所有这些东西——所有的速通玩家现在肯定对我们很生气——是的，我知道我们会收到邮件，Discord 上会因为这个吵翻天。嗯，
in isolation, they're trivial, right? In isolation, they're trivial to overcome, but it's when you compose them in different ways that it becomes really interesting. And, uh, um, and so, you know, start with something really simple. Uh, everyone says this, I'm not inventing something new here, but, but start with something simple that's very scripted and then work your way up by adding more and more complex systems. And again, like a library, I mean, a tool chain like Godot
单独来看，它们微不足道，对吧？单独来看，克服它们很简单，但当你以不同的方式组合它们时，它就变得非常有趣了。所以，从非常简单的东西开始。每个人都这么说，我不是在发明什么新东西，但从非常简单、高度脚本化的东西开始，然后通过添加越来越复杂的系统来逐步提升。再说一次，像 Godot 这样的工具链
is really important for that. I don't know why we're on subjective game dev advice. Having never built a game, I would say I think one of the things too, but, but I guess cross cross pollinating from other stuff is don't set out to build your dream game first. I mean, that does work. There are stories. You can Google them about people who like their very first game was successful and amazing
对于这一点非常重要。我不知道为什么我们在谈论主观的游戏开发建议。作为一个从未开发过游戏的人，我想说，从其他领域借鉴经验的一点是：不要一开始就试图构建你的梦想游戏。我的意思是，这确实行得通。你可以去谷歌搜索那些第一款游戏就成功且惊人的故事，
or whatever. But I think much more common, like set your sights on something like attainable. You can, you can, you can kind of iterate on the the dream game the fantasy game the one day i'm going to build this but for now you know sort of just execute on on you know sort of what what's in your in your scope to finish and get sort of the reps in of you know start to end and actually sort of doesn't have to be amazing or you don't have to you don't have to send it to anyone but just like complete and playable uh and you know have a beginning and a middle and an end and jason mentioned game jams,
或者其他什么。但我认为更常见的情况是，设定一个可实现的目标。你可以不断迭代那个梦想游戏、那个幻想游戏，那个“总有一天我会构建它”的游戏。但现在，执行你能力范围内能完成的事情，获得从头到尾的经验。它不需要非常惊人，你也不必把它发给任何人，只要完成且可玩，有一个开始、中间和结尾。杰森提到了游戏开发马拉松，
but this is my like secret thing. It's like one day I'm going to sign up for a game jam. He's going to force me to do this. Like it's time bound. We need to do it, Patrick. Oh, no, we need to do it. We got to take like three days off work
这是我的秘密武器。总有一天我会报名参加一个游戏开发马拉松。他会强迫我这么做。这有时间限制，我们需要完成它，帕特里克。哦不，我们需要这么做。我们得请三天假，
when there's a game jam and make a game. All right. I got to do practice before that. But all right. The line is drawn. Trying to get back onto Godot. Physics, we didn't talk about as well this is another one where maybe people either think it's too easy or too hard but uh having a physics
在游戏开发马拉松期间制作一款游戏。好吧，我得在那之前练习一下。但好吧，界限已经划定了。回到 Godot。物理引擎，我们还没谈到，这也是人们要么觉得太简单要么觉得太难的地方。但拥有一个物理
engine and not worrying about all the things that that come with it collision detection you know right gravity adding you know parameters that you can script to other functions or actions or superpowers like jason mentioned know, having a boot that turns off the spikes, right? Like you want to code all that logic with a, you know, spaghetti function, look, like, yeah, you could do that. You know, or you could let a system that sort of has all those things, you know, handle it for you. Yeah, I mean, another thing that's really complicated is, you know, look at Mario, for example for example you know certain things are affected by physics like uh like the mushroom falling off the edge of a ledge or something right um but then you
引擎，而不必担心随之而来的所有事情，比如碰撞检测、重力、添加可以脚本化到其他函数、动作或超能力的参数。就像杰森提到的，有一个能关掉尖刺的靴子，对吧？你想用一个意大利面条式的函数来编写所有这些逻辑吗？看，是的，你可以那样做。或者你可以让一个已经具备所有这些功能的系统为你处理。是的，我的意思是，另一个非常复杂的事情是，看看《马力欧》，某些东西受物理影响，比如蘑菇从边缘掉下来，对吧？但有些东西你需要更多的控制。如果马力欧由物理引擎控制，那将太不可靠了，
know there's certain things where you just need a lot more control like if mario is controlled by a physics engine it would be just too unreliable and uh you know obviously speed runners would be really upset it's like oh you know my computer you know skipped a frame and mario couldn't make that jump or something but but then also like you know it would just be too complicated for for beginner players to really understand you know so so so you need mario where when you jump he has an extremely fixed trajectory uh he could even change trajectory in midair and things that are like physically unplausible um but then you need you know mushrooms and barrels and stuff that are just normal physics things and so you know godot has uh I'm not going to get the terminology right, but it basically
显然速通玩家会非常生气，比如“哦，我的电脑跳帧了，马力欧没跳过去”之类的。但同时，对于新手玩家来说，这也太复杂了，无法真正理解。所以你需要马力欧在跳跃时拥有极其固定的轨迹，他甚至可以在半空中改变轨迹，这些在物理上是不可能的。但你需要蘑菇、木桶之类的东西，它们是正常的物理对象。所以 Godot 有——我可能记不住术语了，但它基本上
has a concept for, I think they call it a static dynamic body or something. I don't remember. Anyways, but there's a concept for like, here's a thing that I want to exist in my physics universe, but I'm going to be controlling it directly. And you'd use that for something like a player. I think it's called a kinematic body. And then they have dynamic bodies so you could just use little circles you know to represent the mushrooms and the barrels and everything um and they they handle like what happens when one type of body bounces
有一个概念，我想他们叫它静态/动态物体之类的。我不记得了。总之，有一个概念是：“这是一个我想在我的物理宇宙中存在的物体，但我将直接控制它。”你会用它来做玩家角色。我想它叫运动学物体（Kinematic Body）。然后他们有动态物体（Dynamic Bodies），所以你可以用小圆圈来代表蘑菇和木桶等等。它们处理当一种物体反弹
off another one because that's another issue is like you know what if you have like total control over mario let's say there's something like a barrel and mario pushes the barrel against the wall you know what happens is that barrel gets squeezed and then explode you know like you see in physics engines i go flying or does mario stop moving like there's all this complexity and uh the game engine you know will really help you navigate all of that talking about barrels and pushing in this i think um also and you can correct me if i'm wrong but i was telling jace is one of those things who pops up with discord uh not in our discord just in general which is entity component systems uh like one of those game development philosophies so i think good joe jason mentioned
撞击另一种物体时会发生什么，因为这是另一个问题，比如如果你对马力欧有完全控制权，假设有一个木桶，马力欧把木桶推向墙壁，你知道会发生什么吗？木桶是被挤压然后爆炸，还是像你在物理引擎中看到的那样飞出去，还是马力欧停止移动？这里面有所有的复杂性，游戏引擎真的会帮你处理所有这些。谈到木桶和推动，我想，你可以纠正我，但我告诉杰森，这是 Discord 上经常出现的话题，不是我们的 Discord，而是普遍意义上的，即实体组件系统（ECS），这是游戏开发哲学之一。我认为 Godot，杰森提到了
scenes and the sort of hierarchy um but i think good dough famously does not sort of natively push the entity component system uh which is one way of handling what we're talking about which is hey you have all these things moving around you have enemies and you have you know rotating fire flame arms and swords and pickups and all of these things need to be sort of tracked inventories and what's in your backpack and you and all of these things need to be sort of tracked inventories and what's in your backpack and you know all of these things you know need to be handled rendered updated every frame and so it becomes a a place to sort of you know be be rigorous in how you're going to not handle each specific object uniquely but handle sort of all objects collectively in a in
场景和层级结构，但我认为 Godot 并不原生推崇实体组件系统，这是处理我们所谈论内容的一种方式，即你有所有这些东西在移动，你有敌人，你有旋转的火焰臂、剑、拾取物，所有这些东西都需要被追踪，比如库存、背包里有什么，所有这些东西
a common way and have a common sort of thing. And so the entity component system approach, oh, I'm going to see if I can get this right. So entities are roughly sort of IDs into the world. So rather than everything being a pointer, you give everything a unique ID so that the system can refer to other IDs and do things like garbage collection off frame
都需要被处理、渲染、每一帧更新。所以它变成了一个需要严谨对待的地方，不是唯一地处理每个特定对象，而是以一种通用的方式处理所有对象。所以实体组件系统的方法，哦，我看看能不能说对。实体（Entities）大致是世界中的 ID。所以与其让一切都成为指针，你给一切一个唯一的 ID，这样系统就可以引用其他 ID，并做一些事情，比如在帧外进行垃圾回收，
or phasing them out or changing them between levels. And so entities are, and then the component is sort of like the thing in the sort of inheritance hierarchy. It's like, it is an object, it has properties and attributes that you can add, and they can be common across like this is a, this is a barrel. Do you want barrels to be destroyable or not? So does it have a destroyable attribute or it's not is it squishy or non is it rigid or not rigid i guess there we go uh and then the system is the yeah the thing that runs it right it hooks up all of the calls that need to be routed between each other and does the updates and sort of flows everything through um and it's a a way of modeling um this that the other places take i think there's some sort of extensions to Godot that will allow you to implement this.
或者在关卡间切换时将其移除。所以实体是……然后组件（Component）有点像继承层级中的东西。它是一个对象，拥有你可以添加的属性和特性，它们可以是通用的，比如“这是一个木桶”。你想要木桶是可破坏的还是不可破坏的？所以它有一个可破坏属性，或者它是软的还是硬的，是刚性的还是非刚性的，我想就是这样。然后系统（System）就是运行它的东西，对吧？它连接所有需要在彼此之间路由的调用，进行更新，并让一切流动起来。这是一种建模方式，其他地方也采用这种方式。我想 Godot 有一些扩展可以让你实现这一点。
It's not a game engine unique thing. You could develop other code that uses the same kind of logic. But this is just one of the things some game engines use. And then Godot uses a sort of hierarchy instead through sort of inheritance to show some of this and sort of a more i think am i am i sort of on the right track yeah no you're nailing it yeah yeah okay good uh but this is one of those trade-offs that your game engine i think it's a little bit you know i described like
这不是游戏引擎独有的。你可以开发使用相同逻辑的其他代码。但这只是某些游戏引擎使用的方法之一。而 Godot 通过继承使用了一种层级结构来展示其中的一些内容，这更……我是不是走在正确的轨道上？是的，你说得对。好的。但这正是游戏引擎的权衡之一，我认为它有点……你知道，我描述了一个菜单，但它可能自带自己的方法，它并不阻止你使用不同的方法，或者深入使用 ECS，但它不是开箱即用的。它不会为你做所有的管道工作。人们会为此写长篇博客，讨论这种方法的利弊。是的，很久以前我尝试用 C++ 从零开始制作游戏，
a menu but it's sort of like it may bring its own approach it doesn't prevent you from using something different and really going in in in sort of the ecs the entity component system, but it's sort of out of the box. It's not going to kind of do all that piping for you. And this is one of those people will go a pine for long blog posts about the pros or cons of such an approach. Yeah, I mean, one thing where I tried to make a game a long time ago, just in C++ from scratch,
我尝试编写自己的游戏引擎，它并不……但公平地说，那是一个基于文本的游戏，像那种 Roguelike 游戏，我不需要很多图形。但当时真正让我困扰的一件事是循环引用。你知道，如果我有一把剑，那么人拥有这把剑，剑附着在人身上。你如何优雅地打破这种引用？例如，如果你有一把剑，比如一把魔法剑，10 秒后消失？它是咒语的一部分，对吧？当你挥剑时，10 秒到了，你知道，会有一些奇怪的事情，比如“哦，剑消失了，但你已经挥剑了”，所以你会得到这些奇怪的效果。
I tried to write my own game engine, it was not um but to be fair it was a text base is like one of these rogue type games where i didn't need a lot of graphics but um one of the things that really tripped me up back then was circular references you know like if i if i have a sword then like the person has the sword, the sword's attached to the person. And just like what, how do you break that reference elegantly? Like, for example, what if you have a sword that is like a, you know, like a magical sword that disappears after 10 seconds? Like it's part of a spell, right? And like as you're swinging the sword the 10 seconds are up you know like there's weird things like that where like oh you know the sword disappeared but now like you know you'd already committed to swinging the sword so you get these weird effects
是的，Godot 做的一件事是它有一种队列系统，你将一个对象排队等待释放，但它会保留它一会儿，以确保你不会遇到这种死锁问题。这修复了我遇到的各种问题，特别是在《AI Hero》中切换关卡并试图拆除所有东西时。有了 Godot，它就帮我处理了所有这些。但我知道在过去的项目中，我遇到过很多问题，甚至 Mame Hub 在退出时都会崩溃，我至今不知道怎么修复。所以，它确实为你减轻了处理
right um and you know one thing godot does it has this like a type of queuing system where you queue an object to be freed but it kind of keeps it around for a little bit longer just to make sure that you don't have this this uh uh sort of uh so it's a form of deadlock in a way sort of deadlock issue um and and that fixed uh a variety of issues i had especially when i was changing levels in AI hero and I was trying to like tear everything down. Um, you know, with Godot, it just kind of like took care of all of that for me, but I know in past projects, you know, I've had a bunch of issues where even Mame Hub, Mame Hub crashes on exit and I still don't know how to fix it. So, so, um, you know, it kind of alleviates all of those those issues for you of
C++ 指针混乱的所有问题。说到 C++，我们还没说 Godot 的编程语言，你想谈谈替代方案吗？好的，好主意。所以 Godot 使用一种叫 GDScript 的语言。你见过这个吗，帕特里克？是的，它和 Python 非常相似，只有几个微小的区别。但我发现它在开始时非常容易上手。老实说，我不想学习另一种语言，所以我尝试用 C# 使用 Godot，他们叫它 Godot Mono，但那简直是问题重重。我尝试的时候它还是全新的，那是 Godot 3，我遇到了太多技术问题，我就想：“好吧，AI Hero 里没多少代码，让我学学这个 GDScript 试试。”我很高兴我
dealing with you know c++ pointer nastiness um speaking of c++ we haven't said so godot programming languages do you you want to take the alternative yeah um good good call man um so yeah so godot uses something called gd script uh have you seen this patrick yes yeah it's it's very similar to python um there's just a few tiny differences but uh um but yeah i found it very approachable in the beginning um i didn't want to have to learn another language to be honest so i thought let me try godot with the c sharp there is a she they call it godot mono um but that was just plagued with issues i mean it was brand new when i was trying it out this was godot 3 and um it's just i just had so many technical issues I was like let me you know there's not that much code in AI hero let me just learn try out this Godot script and I'm so glad I
这么做了。我的意思是，几乎没花什么时间就学会了。只有一些非常细微的区别，比如在 Python 中，当你想要获取……如果你想对对象列表进行 for 循环，但同时也需要索引，你需要对象及其索引，在 Python 中你会写 `for x in enumerate(my_list)`，对吧？我想 Godot 有点不同，但就是这些非常细微的事情。作为交换，这是一种更好的开发者体验。现在我认为 C# 已经成熟多了，我想你也可以用 C++ 做事。所以 C++、C#、GDScript，这些是核心语言，然后还有其他语言的通用绑定。如果你
did I mean it took almost no time to learn um you know there's just a few like really subtle differences like I think you know in Python you use enumerate when you want to get a uh um so if you want to get like if you want to uh do a for loop over a list of objects but you also need the index so you need the object and its index at the same time in python you do like 4x in enumerate my list right i think good oh it's something different but it's like these kind of really minor things um and in exchange like you know it was such a better developer experience um now i think the c-sharp is getting much more mature i think you can also do stuff uh in c++ as well so i think c++ c-sharp gd script those are kind of the the core ones and then i think they're you know like in general bindings for other stuff, if you if
想的话，你可以用，但你开始离开核心功能了。如果你不知道自己是否需要专门做某事，或者你在 Quest 上，你想留在其中一种语言里。我们提到的另一件事，就像我谈到实体组件系统或插件时提到的，我认为游戏引擎带给你的另一件事是核心功能就在那里，并且提供了一些东西，你可以获取其他库来为你做事情。我们谈论 Unity 时提到过，他们有市场，总是像
you kind of want to, but you sort of start to leave the I know there's like some core functionality, you want to kind of stay in if you if you don't know that you need to specifically do something or you're on a, you know, quest, you want to say stay in kind of one of those. So the other thing that we alluded to, like I mentioned, when we were talking about entity component systems or the sort of plugins but i think another thing a game engine gets you is again this like core functionality being there and and offering stuff is you can go get other libraries to do things for you so we've talked about that when we talked about unity and they have sort of the marketplace as always like you
付费和免费的扩展。Godot 也有类似的东西。所以有些东西你可以直接抓取并添加进去，你真的不想从零开始做。你想展示广告，你想展示什么样的广告，比如小横幅广告，你都能得到。或者，请，我甚至不想深入讨论，我自己从没做过。但你想提供解锁，或者应用内购买，或者做一个“请不要”的免费游戏，里面有微交易，你真的想自己编写所有
know paid and free sort of extensions. Godot has something similar. So there's things that you can go grab and just add in that you really wouldn't want to do from scratch. So you want to show ads, what kind of ads you want to show, you know, like little banner ads or like, you're going to get all of that for you. Or, you know, please, I don't even want to go down, never had to do it myself. But like, you want to offer unlocks or you know in-app purchases or do a please don't freemium game that has micro transactions like you really want to code up all
那些东西吗？不。所以，是的，与所有这些不同的服务对话，因为你必须与安卓的谷歌服务和苹果的 iOS 服务对话，所以你至少得写两次代码，而且可能会非常痛苦。Godot 只是处理了它。PC 上的应用内购买等价物是什么？有吗？我其实不知道，比如有 DLC 吗？是的，这是……好吧，有两种微交易，对吧？有 DLC，还有购买化妆品，或者
that stuff by yourself like no so yeah i mean talking to all these different services because you have to talk to the google service for android and the ios service for apple so you're not you you will have to at least code it twice and it's probably going to be very painful godot just handles it what is the in-app equivalent for pc is there one i i don't actually know like is there a dlc right this is okay so like you would just like steam app or through like i don't know like how would okay yeah it's a good so you know i yeah okay there's two types of microtransactions right there's there's dlc and then there's kind of like buying you know uh i guess like cosmetic stuff or
购买游戏中的进度。第二种，我真的不知道你在 PC 上有什么选择，但第一种肯定是 DLC。你可以说，比如《Polytopia》就是一个很好的例子，你必须购买不同的种族才能玩它们，这有点像解锁了更多游戏内容。在 Steam 上，你只需把每个种族做成 DLC，通过那里购买。Godot 在早期有很多针对平台跳跃游戏的教程，以及一些基础的手机游戏，那种休闲游戏，2D 的东西。但我认为，这就是你描述的你的游戏《AI Hero》的样子。但最近他们一直在努力
or buying like advancement in the game right um that second one yeah i really don't know what your options are for pc but the first one would definitely be dlc like you could say you know like polytopia is a good example where uh you have to buy the different races you know to play them and and it kind of like unlocks a bit more of the game um and in steam you just make each race a dlc and buy it through there good though when it was early was a lot of tutorials and stuff for platformers and sort of like you know i guess basic phone games you know the sort of casual casual games i guess like 2d stuff but i think and i think that was what you were describing sort of sort of your game to be to ai here is this sort of like but yeah but recently they've added they've been working
变得功能更全面，作为一个 3D 游戏引擎。是的，我的意思是，我没有这方面的经验，或者 Unity 也是，我很久没做过 3D 了。但 Godot 确实在努力与 Unity 和 Unreal 以及其他替代品在功能上保持一致，这很棒。我个人的建议是，我不会从 3D 游戏开始。人们会说有优势，比如如果你有一个 3D 模型，它不需要看起来像 2D 精灵那么详细。你可以通过艺术方面的东西蒙混过关。我对此持怀疑态度，老实说，我觉得即使在 2D 中，如果你有一个扎实的游戏钩子，你也可以有质量很低的艺术。所以是的，我肯定会从 2D 开始。但 Godot，想想 Godot，如果你最终
pretty hard to become more fully featured as like a 3d game engine as well yeah i mean i don't have any experience with it uh but uh or unity that matter for i haven't done a lot of 3d uh stuff in a long time but um but yeah i think you know godot is trying to be really you know feature complete with unity and unreal and those alternatives, which is great. I wouldn't, my personal advice, I wouldn't start with a 3D game. There are, you know, people will say there's advantages. Like if you have a 3D mesh, it doesn't have to look as detailed as a 2D sprite. Like you could basically get away with a lot more on the art side. I't know i'm a little skeptical of that to be honest i feel like you could have pretty low quality art even in 2d if you have a solid uh game hook um so yeah i would definitely start with with 2d but good dough you know think about good does you if you do eventually
想在游戏行业获得职业发展，或者你有 3D 游戏的愿景，想自己构建它，你可以做所有这些。你可以在 Godot 中成长，并且知道它会支持你想构建的 3D 游戏。回到你的组件系统，有一件事让我印象深刻，花了我很长时间才习惯，那就是没有“main”函数，没有入口点。它的工作方式是你将函数附加到单个实体上。比如，让我们以马力欧为例，你实际上将代码附加到板栗仔身上，代码会说：“每一帧，向左移动，直到撞到墙，然后向右移动。”你实际上只是把代码附加到板栗仔身上，它就漂浮在
want to get a career in gaming or you do you know you have a vision for a 3d game you want to build yourself up to it you know you could do the whole thing you could build yourself up in godot and know that it'll it'll support your 3d game that you want to build um getting back to your component system something that really struck me that took a while for me to get used to is there's no like main function you know like there's no entry point so the way it works is you attach functions to individual entities so like i attach this function to like uh let's just use mario as an example so you'd actually attach code to a goomba and that code would say like every tick you know move left until i hit a wall then move right and you would like actually just attach that code to the goomba and it just floats
隔离状态中。你可以把同样的代码附加到乌龟身上。你甚至可以在代码中说，90% 是一样的，但你可以加一个子句说：“如果是乌龟，那么让马力欧把我从活乌龟变成壳。”等等。所以你可以做一些配对之类的，但它不像传统的程序，你从 main 开始，设置一些东西，然后有一个循环遍历所有角色。没有那种东西，你是在写一小段代码，并依赖引擎来系统化所有这些。这需要花很多时间去习惯，写出
in isolation and you could attach that same code to the turtle uh you could even say in that code like 90 of it's the same but you could even have a clause saying like, if turtle, then like, uh, let Mario turn me into like from a living turtle to a shell or whatever. Um, but, uh, so, so you can do some peering and stuff, but it's not like a traditional program where you start with main and then you set up some things and then you have a for loop that loops through all your characters. Like there's none of that like you're writing like little tiny snippets of code and you're relying on the engine to systematize all of that um that was something that took a ton of getting used to and writing
不垃圾的代码，以那种方式，确实需要很多练习。但一旦我习惯了，我真的很喜欢它。我喜欢我可以创建一个新东西，给它一些代码，它就能生活在现有的宇宙中。那部分真的很令人兴奋。好吧，作为我们两个中真正用 Godot 写过游戏的人，你得给它打个分。是的，我试过 Unity，试过 Phaser 和一堆这些，我绝对给 Godot A+，我真的很喜欢它。我没从我的游戏中赚到钱，我的游戏完全免费，没有应用内购买之类的。但如果我赚了，我会把所有钱都给 Godot，他们应得的。所以 Godot 得到了
code that was not garbage uh in that way was actually took a lot of practice um uh but uh but i also once i got used to it i really enjoyed it i like the fact that you know i could just like create a new thing give it some code and it could just live in the in the existing universe um that part of it was really exciting well being the uh one of the two of us that have actually written a game in godot all right you gotta give it a rating yeah so you know i've tried unity um you know i've tried phaser and a bunch of these i definitely give godot an a plus i really loved it um i didn't make any money off my game my game's totally free there's no in-app purchase or anything but if i did i would give all that money to godot they deserve it um so the godot gets a hundred percent
100% 的收益，100% 的零。杰森真是个慈善家。我真的很印象深刻，老实说，我认为如果你刚开始，这无疑是最好的选择。Godot 是开源的，完全开源。你可以分叉它，你可以修改它。我的意思是，所有这些。我们没谈到那个。
of the proceeds from a hundred percent of zero philanthropist to jason such a philanthropist um i was really really impressed honestly i think if you're getting started this is unquestionably the way to go. You know, I think that Godot is open source, totally open source. You can fork it. You can make changes to it. I mean, all of that. We didn't talk about that.
那不是我会使用它的原因。我实际上认为它简单得多。Unity 非常非常复杂。当然，这肯定有优势。但我认为如果你刚开始，Godot 是一种非常美妙、非常简单的体验。就像 Next.js 一样，它非常有主见。正如我所说，没有 main 函数来处理全局数据。你必须使用这个特殊的全局对象。起初，我对它那种主观的性质感到有点沮丧。
That's not the reason I would use it. I actually think it is much simpler. Unity is very, very complicated. And, you know, there's definitely advantages to that. But I think if you're starting out, Godot is just such a beautiful, very simple experience. In the same way as Next.js, it is very opinionated. As I said, there's no main function, you know, for your global data. You know, you have to do it using this like special global object. And in the beginning, I was a little frustrated with all of the sort of the opinionated nature of it.
但一旦我完成了，当我发布游戏时，在那一刻，我完全理解了他们为什么做出那些设计决定。所以我绝对认为 Godot 是一个很好的起点。有一个非常稳固的社区。你永远不必担心许可问题或任何类似的事情。即使你的游戏不是大热门，处理专业 Unity 账户的繁文缛节也很多，我甚至不知道那是什么。哦，你知道，用 Godot，当我的游戏准备好时，我就发布了。所以是的，我
But once, you know, at the end of it, when I launched my game, at that point, I had totally come to understand why they had made those design decisions. So I definitely think Godot is a great place to get started. There's a really solid community. And you never have to worry about licensing issues or any of that. Even if your game isn't a huge hit know it's still a lot of red tape to have to jump through uh getting the professional unity account or i don't even know what it is oh you know with godot it's like when my game was ready you know i just shipped it so uh so yeah i'd
强烈推荐它。有一件事，哦，有 Godot 3 和 Godot 4。我跳上 Godot 4 的车有点太早了，它当时状况很糟糕。你实际上回不去。如果你去了 4，你就回不到 3，除非你通过源代码控制，显然，但你会丢失在 4 中取得的任何进展。但在这一点上，我认为 4 已经足够成熟，人们可以直接
highly recommend it um there's one thing oh there's uh godot 3 and god 4. I jumped on the Godot 4 bandwagon a little bit too early, and it was in rough shape. You actually can't go back. If you go to 4, you can't go back to 3 unless you, you know, you can with source control, obviously, but you lose whatever progress you've made in 4. But at this point, I think 4 is mature enough that folks can go straight
去用 Godot 4，这很有趣。太棒了。好吧，你之前提到了，向 Patreon 的支持者致敬，感谢所有支持我们和收听我们节目的人。这是一期很棒的节目。游戏开发，我们总是谈论这个，这是每个人都会尝试进入的第一件事。所以这是一个很好的切入点。我本来想说“毒品”，那听起来很糟糕。
to good to four and uh and it's uh it's been a lot of fun awesome well you know you mentioned earlier but you know shout out to the shout out to the patreon sticking with us and all our supporters and people listening to us i this is a great episode uh game development we always talk about that it's like one of those first things that everyone and all our supporters and people listening to us. This is a great episode. Game development, we always talk about that. It's like one of those first things that everyone always attempts to get in. And so it's a great gateway. I was going to say drug, that sounds bad.
切入点，只是切入点。伟大的编程切入点。伟大的切入点。这很难说，伟大的切入点。伟大的切入点，是的。伟大的盖茨比。所以是的，它
Gateway, just gateway. The great gateway to programming. The great gateway. That's a hard thing to say, great gateway. Great gateway, yep. The great Gatsby. So yeah, it's,
太棒了。谢谢。是的，正如帕特里克所说，非常感谢我们的赞助人。我们要进行赠品活动。所以如果你曾经想成为 Programming Throwdown 的赞助人，现在是一个好时机。
it's awesome. Thanks. Yeah. As Patrick said, thanks so much for our patrons. We're going to do the giveaway. So if you've ever wanted to be a programming throwdown patron, now is a great time.
太棒了，谢谢。正如帕特里克所说，非常感谢我们的赞助人。我们将进行抽奖活动，所以如果你一直想成为Programming Throwdown的赞助人，现在正是好时机。
You could theoretically make money where you could be a patron for a dollar, get a prize and then punch out. You know, we'll, we won't. We won't hold it against you. I will say, actually, I feel a little bit bad. I said this is private, so it's not actually incriminating anyone. Someone did do something interesting. Elect to become a patron, send me a message saying they should be on our show, and then cancel their patronage before we even got one dollar.
理论上你可以通过这种方式赚钱，比如花一美元成为赞助人，拿到奖品然后就退出。你知道，我们不会，我们不会怪你。其实我得说，我感到有点不好意思。我说过这是私下的，所以实际上并没有指控任何人。确实有人做了一件有趣的事。选择成为赞助人，给我发消息说他们应该上我们的节目，然后在我们收到一美元之前就取消了赞助。
I thought that was clever, but I didn't respond. I felt like that was maybe beyond the pale. But being a patron, you know, giving us one buck and then winning a T-shirt, I think, is totally above water. I'm totally quoted. Unethical life pro tips right here. Patrick is shaking his head. I'm out, man. I'm totally cool with it. Unethical life pro tips right here. Patrick is shaking his hand. I'm not, man. I'm not.
我觉得这很聪明，但我没有回复。我觉得这可能有点过分了。但成为赞助人，你知道，给我们一美元然后赢了一件T恤，我认为是完全正当的。我完全被引用了。这就是不道德的生活小窍门。帕特里克在摇头。我退出，伙计。我完全没问题。这就是不道德的生活小窍门。帕特里克在握手。我没有，伙计。我没有。
All right. Well, hey, it's a pleasure to come record the show with Patrick for you all. We have a great time and we will catch you all on the next one. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I, and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的。嘿，很高兴能和帕特里克一起为大家录制节目。我们玩得很开心，我们下期节目再见。音乐由Eric Barn提供。Programming Throwdown采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0许可协议分发。您可以自由分享、复制、传播作品，进行重混、改编，但必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。